the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the players were fast and the play was
furious at the super united rapid
emblems in zagreb croatia it looked to
be a topsy-turvy day at the top of the
standings with multiple lead changes
early that is until reigning world
champion magnus carlson shifted into
high gear and reminded everyone why he
is the best in the world going an
incredible plus five without drawing to
blow past the front runners and claim
sole lead american superstar wesley so
is in second with jordan van forest
rounding out the top three the race is
on can anyone catch the searching titan
the final day of the super united rapid
and blitz coming up next
[Music]
the stage is set for the conclusion of
the super united rapid and blitz here in
zagreb the world champion leads by one
and a half points but he has a pack of
hungry wolves behind him can any of them
catch up we know that blitz is a streaky
sport to find out let's go to our studio
in st louis with miro yasser and
christian
hello everyone and welcome back to our
fifth and final day of live coverage of
the grand chess tour in zagreb croatia
it's been great fun but today we crown a
champion hello from st louis i'm your
host yasser along with nero miro it's
been great fun four days of action my
pleasure yasser yeah and what do you
think after
these four days what has stood out for
you well while leaders were
uh changing each other and yeah actually
like very much the way they put it in
the opener surging titan yes surging
titan yeah so we spent those four days
discussing with yes in great detail how
the surgeon tight titan magnus carson
was not playing at his best right his
opening preparation was not good his
conversion technique was not good
he has
once again proved him the best player in
the world by winning five in a row that
was impressive
absolutely in an interview himself right
he admitted that yeah i've won quite a
few
uh back and forth games and yeah that
puts him on a in the lead well let's
take a look at our standing and we now
we know who's on top who's chasing yeah
who's chasing wesley saw who
interestingly i mean he performs very
well but he's never been on top of the
standings i'm afraid i mean he was
either joined by you're in one forest
who finds himself on the third position
right oh now he's in a bit of a shadow
of magnus carson it's a one and a half
points difference between magnus and
wesley and on fourth position
who had very good blitz tournament but
still quite a distance absolutely
and uh our what are we planning for
today
what's going to be our format and our
schedule for today yeah so format it's
once again a full round robin on blitz
so same nine rounds with colors reversed
same as yesterday game will start every
30 minutes every half an hour five
minutes plus 10 seconds plus two seconds
is the time control right no draw offers
and well traditional traditional points
count and in case of a playoff we'll
talk about that as we get closer but in
the meanwhile we have christian in
studio to tell us about our leaders and
how they got here good morning christian
good to have you in studio good morning
guys bright and early here in saint
louis and the excitement is palpable
these guys have been giving us a lot of
fast and furious action but at the end
of the day it is magnus carlsen who is
in top position going into the final day
and let's take a look how he as well as
his challenger from november 2021 got to
where they are at this point and we're
going to start with the standings after
the rapid time control well magnus
carlsen you can see there after a slow
start started picking up the pace he
finished on 11 points one point behind
the leader at that time
jordan van forest yane pognashi on the
other hand had a very rough rapid time
control only nine points for him three
points behind jordan van forest and
let's take a look what happened in the
blitz section after three rounds of
blitz action magnus carlsen still in
second position but it was wesley saw
who was surging in the rankings 15 and a
half points two and a half points ahead
of magnus carson janna pognashi slowly
but surely was picking up the pace only
one point behind magnus carlsen after
six rounds of play well nothing has
changed in terms of where magnus carlsen
was still in second position tied
actually for second position half a
point behind jordan van forest janna
pomnya she's still two points behind
magnus carlsen but right now in clear
fifth position and after nine rounds
this is where we stand right now magnus
carlsen is surging in the standings one
and a half points ahead of his nearest
rival that is wesley so with 16 and a
half points and janna pomnya she
definitely has had a very good first day
fifteen and a half points and take a
look at that line score for yann
nepomnyashi in the first three rounds
boom boom boom three decisive games big
wins for him to start off day four after
that tame the pace a little bit a big
loss against magnus carlsen his only
loss in the blitz section so far
definitely a beautiful line score for
yane pomnyashi but it is this is the
story of one man and this is the world
champion magnus carlsen after nine
rounds of blitz he is definitely setting
up a fury pace in this tournament five
games he won in the last five rounds
just mr perfect ending the day
yesterday it was just incredible to see
how the world champion is creating
separation in this competition and we
also have our friends in zagreb guys
tell us about the atmosphere there
thank you christian and good morning to
you early in st louis the atmosphere
here has been absolutely electric and
you guys mentioned magnus carlsen has
been the headliner throughout the entire
event anastasia we talked to him the
first day he came here he had this
announcement that he was not going to
defend the world championship title you
thought he was emotional maybe even
affected his play but he's in a much
better mood right now absolutely first
days he looked really sad i don't know
not in the mood but yesterday when he
came here finally in the studio we could
see him smiling he was happy he felt
like he had a really good day right and
today we saw him even in the morning the
breakfast we all know that magnus is not
an early bird at all and he was there
for the breakfast he was laughing he was
with his friends i think he's really in
a good mood and i think he's looking
forward to win this tournament but it's
still not over
absolutely he's in a great mood he
brought a friend and he's had a lot of
fun he's been doing sports he's been
getting up early and he is in the mood
to finish this one off guys nine rounds
of blitz the world champion one and a
half points ahead let's see if anybody
can even touch him in this tournament
thank you uh anastasia and alejandro and
set the table for what we can expect for
this round 10
of blitz mural oh yeah so well round 10
as i said it's well it's the same round
robert went with scholars reverse so
well reflects the first round of
yesterday saric against mvl dominguez
against nepal wesley saw his mommy jarop
the palo firuja and one forest finally
gets his first chance to play white
against magnus carlsen so this will be a
key matchup of course absolutely and van
poros lost twice
with the black pieces let's see what he
can do with the white pieces and they've
been fighting very very hard these last
four days what are they fighting for
yeah they're fighting for a chunk of
money right 175
000 in total 40 000 for the first price
30 for the second 25 for the third and
so on absolutely and there you see
wesley so chatting with our photographer
leonard otis who also
mans the dgt boards making sure the
transmissions all work and
well final day of blitz coming up
um
any early predictions
five in a row
for
magnus can he make it a car you wanna
yeah and score seven
what do you think about that he could
you'd have to start with a win
interestingly you will have to start
with the winning and follow it up with
the win you have to make it seven that's
make it seven
right his next opponent is wrestling
parlov magnus is going to have white so
that's a very important that's a very
important game
uh first game well i wanted to say
morning game it's not morning for them
but still right you know blitz i believe
it's all about the written though
long blitz tournaments so yesterday he
was on the role so i believe he wished
this tournament to continue to go on
right right so today even though
technically he is still on strict but
it's a new day and it's very important
you know to have good results in those
opening grounds absolutely christian
weigh in do you think we're going to see
a car ijuana well this is the big one i
have a feeling the game between jordan
van forest and magnus because these
players know each other once again very
very uh well at the same time jordan has
been saying yeah
i'm very happy with my results so far
i'm not very ambitious that is nonsense
he is extremely ambitious he wants to
win this tournament as well and if he is
to keep up pace with the leader with
magnus carson he needs to win this game
so jordan definitely with the white
pieces will try to pile on the pressure
early on but he is playing magnus carson
after all joey we saw the honorable
opening move i must say that junior
player who did it e2e4 with
was it precision energy yeah let's go
and uh wesley and here we go i
appreciated the this one
started with a handshake unlike some
other games right right e4 e5
okay
bishop c5
and i think we've actually seen a djoko
piano with the reversed cards
bishop b6 they're rapid right
not d6 and now queen to e7 that's a
wrinkle
absolutely very very new wrinkle now
i guess if you go d5 you either either
put the knight on b8 or d8 is that it is
that d8 i think he's definitely going
for a d5 but then from d8 where is that
knight going are you going to go to f7
i think so
this is extremely confusing to me yeah
that it is a confusing setup yeah do we
have d5 no i i think he's going to go
knight b8 yeah i think like b8 i mean
and then d6 and knight d7 that makes
the most sense funny to say but just
retreating to the initial square seems
to never mind the idea it is on the
board no an idea
yes it's
very confusing
absolutely
i suspect that there's going to be quite
a bit of maneuvering going on in this
game the bishop on c4
wrongly placed you probably want to play
bishop d3 c4 bring the knight to c3 okay
guys but
you want to go to f7 right so you're
going to play the move f6 but where
where is the other knight going the
knight goes to d7 and to wow
i was thinking about this forget
everything i was just about to say this
uh positional pawn sacrifice okay
right right it doesn't feel like it
meets the requirements of the position
you like that i know you like it i love
that
but it wasn't right because now the
finally the knight can go back to c6 or
e3
and when white when black plays knight
f6 uh unfortunately
the e pawn needs protection so i don't
like this desirable rook d1 knight
honestly very strange pawn sacrifice
exactly exactly
here the move knight g4 i would find
very attractive just because it provokes
rookie two and then when i go knight e6
don't go knight d2
uh-huh this is a nice way of doing it as
well
because
knight g4 oh
i don't like this it's just he's playing
i don't like this in the wrongs on the
wrong side of the board also he's not
developing his pieces that's a big
problem right uh well okay maybe he's
just trying to prove that okay you do
have some activity but your bishop on c8
isn't unlikely to join the game yes
maybe that's the point of your in one
forest no questions he's gonna push a5
if he's allowed to right and then meet
b6 with a6 bishop c7 yeah but that's the
problem right he's basically a5 bishop
c7 yeah he has to has to play a5 again
f5 i guess yeah because b7 b6 and
probably bishop
uh
whoa
rook to ba he wants to play b5 e5 in one
go like b7 b5 is a plan right okay
b7 b5 and then
poisson to recapture i suppose with the
bishop but essentially the bishop wants
to go to b7 to pressure the pawn on e4
knight eight three knight
intermediate aiming it yeah
knight to c2 and then knight to b4 and
what do you think about the speed of the
play
both players seem to
just be hitting the accelerator here
yeah but it's blitz yeah right
it feels like he plays as fast as if he
would know the line but right now i'm
looking at the one for its clock it's
three minutes out of five he spent a lot
of time on d5 and then he spent some
more on d6 okay so those were the two
big moves
uh again i'm quite skeptical of the pawn
sacrifice myself unless
blac a white pardon me manages a very
quick transfer of his knight to f5
perhaps
restore equality right after bishop
takes a6
ah but there's knight c5 at the end
precisely with the four six on the e4
pawn so if we excuse me
if we take on a6 after the trade there
will be a rook on a6
and it will be met with knight to c5
attacking a white rook on a6 as well as
the pawn on e4 so should we start with a
move a b4 first
b4 to take away the square
he plays
knight before okay a5 is less obvious
yeah did he know
he goes bishop b7 i'm thinking bishop b7
just attacked upon targeting e4 exactly
also the move knight c5 was
possible yeah so yeah guard the pawn you
attack the e4 exactly that kind of fair
enough but he also wants to keep control
over d5 right yeah
we see knight d2 on the board knight to
d2 knight d2 this is where the move
knight g4 knight f4 a moment ago i had
mentioned there was always also this
possibility of kind of
trying to wrong foot the rook i think
the rookie has to go to f1 if you
precisely we'll have to go back to f1
absolutely that will be the case and you
would love to have castle already done
so that you can play f5 and try to open
up even more pressure what about
knight c5 just hitting oops excuse me
knight c5 just hitting the pawn on e4
again maybe don't play f3 don't play f3
that
that bishop will be
an ambush
i like that move
and by the way just to give you an
update yeah it does seem like wesley saw
is much better against mamedyarov
okay
okay magnus ends up playing a5 pushing
the knight to d5 you do you don't want
to occupy the d5 square with a pawn
though
yeah so bishop takes bishop takes trades
the knight says and now it's an extra
pawn for and even better still uh that
uh king is going to be so okay safe it's
got to be got to be almost 20 for for
black the rook uh pardon me the pawn on
f2 as well as the rooker under attack
rook e2 or rook
rookie to splunky too i'm expecting
oops excuse me
sorry about that i'm expecting king e7
to quickly play rook and challenge the
knight
ask the knight what it wants to do
yeah sevens played
you better play bishop e3
thanks to this pawn on on d7 knight
takes and knight c6
is not possible and you know what the
problem is what's that black is still a
pawn up
yeah that's that that's a big problem in
this position even though it's a double
pawn that doesn't saturn is useful it is
such a good pawn right yeah it protects
the king on the seventh ranked the pawn
on d7 so you cannot
garner any sort of uh initiative
via the seventh rank i think it's
perfectly safe right now for black i
think it's bishop e3 or best for
um
time to try to pull the brakes as fast
as possible right and he goes forward
yes
exactly so
but yeah take back like just cops
he takes back with the knight he's
gunning for that f5 square but b2 pawn
is hanging right but there's that knight
five chuck
i'm not sure
why is it so bad well so you take with
what unbeaten
well with rook right rook takes
with g6 yeah just the moment
but i was thinking rook takes b2 and i
would probably be happy i don't think
there's a good way to defend that pawn
yeah that's the thing like how do you
how do you guarantee a2 is going to be
met with knight c1 how about knight c4
knight c4 rook c8
rogue station
goes rook takes a5 so now black can
capture b2 he has done it takes knight
takes exactly and now you see the
usefulness of the yeah
it's a pride and joy i would go so far
as to say at this moment rook c8
extra pawn
it's almost feeling technically winning
yeah absolutely it's got to be the
position plays itself i mean you could
you can return the knight back to c5 if
you need them exactly but magnus is not
going to slow play right maybe
maybe f5 f4
but knight to a4 now no knight to c for
him
yeah why not the real end game is
winning which it is well the worst part
is this pawn on d5 without a colleague
to protect protect it
uh the king could easily knight to d2
he's going to e4
this is over guys yep king 294 and it's
it's by the way king e2 wasn't the best
oh that walks into a a nasty fourth oh
my god
you can actually resign right now right
you lose you have to play rook a5 but
then
you're losing so bad
uh
the the c3 pawn as well rook takes
oh he captures with the knight that's a
surprise wait a second knight e4 is
beautiful i was thinking
knight d1 was the same trick but 94 is
even very impressive as magnus carlsen
extreme extends his streak
to six in a row let's jump over to the
wesley sew versus shakriar mamidarov
game
um boom boom boom wesley is much better
the two bishops and everything more
active
is is is really tender the a5 pawn rook
takes and bishop b6 and bishop b6 yes
make a harvest of the queen side wesley
is looking good looking the problem is
once you take on a5 and you defend that
pawn on b4 with bishop c3 i have a3 yeah
that's such and i'm picking up
the last pawn in the position uh true
that
i i once was victimized but now knight
bishop before and we go into this
same color bishop
there's only five
bishops
bishop c3 with the light squared bishop
i was about to say a4 your move a3 is
perfectly wonderful that with the bishop
on c3 and the light squared bishop a4
but
easy easy winning at this point another
game uh
that's caught your eye mural
because this game is just
uh
i think we should stay with this one
yeah okay well just because he's uh he's
in second place wesley is in second
place
whoa bishop c7 and there was a that's
the last one slight hesitation like i'm
not walking into any
checkmates am i that is a nice one i'm
not sure
bishops
and now once again bishop to a5 and c3
and now you have to connect the
classical past pawns
right yes you bring the f3 to d3 king
while the king is running i think the f3
is of course running after this age well
it's time to get the uh a pawn on the
express white should be much faster of
course yes
and to get the runners going yeah and
that was a very uh
very impressive play and you said nepo
wait a second nepo i think he had
well close to decisive advantage but
things are not that sure anymore
because dominguez was pawned down he
managed to create this you know the
parcel candidate the h
h pawn
which is the most dangerous very
annoying to stop yeah precisely right
the rook pawns are the most annoying
okay f5 we expect h5 i mean you have a
lot of options you can you can take on
g6 in fact yeah bishop here g3
g2 bishop e3 wait a sec
knight h6 he's on time right
i mean you promote h6 yeah
knight f3 and then check from e5 and put
the knight on f7 on f7 and um
h yeah
the knight goes to f7 you stop the pawn
and you still have an extra pawn on the
other wing precisely
five and let's go knight eighth shade
that's funny i'm not sure about this
knight h8 though it was a strange move i
i agree
and
i don't think you want it okay
just a little bit
so you you you shoulder yeah he's trying
to shoulder the king away
he's trying to shoulder king c3 king d5
that type of thing
yeah
right
a5
wait a second why did we do a5
a5 was really strange right
i'm not 100 sure this is the greatest
technique that uh okay the knight put
some sort of a barrier right yeah
because any time he goes no i don't have
seven was it was a really nice one
knight g5 check is the problem and how
did uh saric versus uh embry alpha and
vl finish
it hasn't
we spoke about the two victories pardon
me the seven victories and two losses
for magnus yesterday ivan cervich was
the mirror opposite
seven losses and two wins for ivan
now it makes it eight and two right
right carlson won yet another one
lost yet another one uh four decisive
games out of the five played only one
draw
and our world champion um
magnus doing great how how did all the
other games go christian well let's take
a look at how wesley got into that
winning position that we moved to in the
middle of the round e4 e5 against
mamedyarov and mamedyarov opened up with
the petrov that's quite a surprise we
don't generally see this in classical
from mamadiarov but in blitz you would
expect something much more aggressive
from such an active player and wesley
decided to play this line with queen to
d tonight to d4 and long castle
preparing an attack on the king side
he's going to move the pawns down the
board h4 h5 and try to checkmate the
blacking on the other side black is
going to try to do the same thing but on
the kings on the queen side against the
white queen the white king on c1 excuse
me h4 a6 h5 now you have to defend
against h6 if you allow me to soften up
the dark squares around your king with
the move h6 you are just simply
strategically losing you cannot allow
that so he played the move h6 bishop to
e2 and by the way wesley was playing
very fast up to at this point bishop to
e2 prepares the move g4 and once again
continuing uh the attack knight to e5
and this seems to have been the big
mistake in the position because g4 is
still possible once you take on g4 i'm
going to be able to go rook to g1 and
then your pawn on h6 is going to be very
tender i'm going to pick that up take
advantage of the fact that the pawn on
g7 is pinned to the king so you cannot
take on g4 he realizes that and plays
the move a b5 rook to g1 c5 but after
knight to f5 and this exchange now white
has everything they want in the position
bishop takes h6 is coming i can also
focus on the pawn on d6 that is a
weakness as well and this is exactly how
wesley so took advantage of uh his
better position queen to d5 bishop to f6
rook to d1 changing the attack from the
g7 pawn which is finally protected by
the bishop to the d6 pawn you have a lot
of weakness
weaknesses in the position as black and
you cannot simply defend all of them and
this is exactly what happened take on b4
your attack is not going anywhere and
i'm picking up a few more pawns as well
queen takes d6 this is where we ended up
in the position and the end game is just
simply winning now let's take a look at
what happened in the game between
topalov and firuja because topalov
despite the fact that they ended up in a
drought apollo had the advantage in this
one c4 and we got an english setup
bishop to e2 queen to c2 at this point
topalov was developing his initiative
quite nicely take a look at this b4
trying to kick this knight away
d4 square is protected by the pawn on e3
so i'm safe on that side in that regard
and let's take a look at how you can
develop the initiative bishop to b2
knight to d7 rook to a1 bishop to a3
this was the moment by the way when i
felt like topalov had the advantage you
have a lot of weaknesses in a black scam
this square f5 that's a problem if i
managed to exchange the light square
bishop and he had the opportunity to do
so with the move knight to d5 he did not
play the move knight to d5 he played the
move e4 allowing black to set up an
outpost on d4 as well that was his
mistake knight to d5 would have given
him quite a nice advantage opposite
color bishops but i have a lot of holes
that i can take advantage of in your
position f5 also tender pawn on f7 this
would have given white the advantage
after the move e4 nothing actually
happened in the game alireza was back in
play and managed to equalize the
position and uh we also have our friends
in zagreb to analyze the other games
guys what do you have
thank you christian and yes we have two
more blitz games you guys caught the end
of that game between lanier dominguez
and janna pomniacci but anastasia what
happened at the beginning at the
beginning it was actually a quite
interesting game it was petrov defense
once again nippon she played with black
pieces uh and
i i think at this point it was really
interesting there was some theoretical
discussion here of course you cannot
take on d5 with queen because bishop h2
is following so
linear decided to exchange queens and
still manage to win this pawn on d5
right so after all those moves we see
that he got the dream he got the pawn he
got the pawn but now look how nepal
played i mean from this point i think he
played really well he really showed what
does it mean to play against hanging
pawns here c3d4 hanging pawns and he
started to play very actively and
threatened them with every move and we
can see that this rook somehow is lost a
little bit after
it moved to h file and after knight d5
you have to find a way how to defend the
spawn roxy one followed rook c4 blocking
those pawns and then then followed with
roxy8 and actually white cannot find a
way how to protect cc pawn so there was
some exchanges in the game and never
moved the game into the ending bishop
against knight classical situation and
he showed really great strengths how he
it was really nice how he outplayed his
opponent just moved
and i think i'm not sure about the move
d5 i mean obviously dominguez was trying
to find some space for his bishop so he
moved this pawn but it turned out to be
a weak weakness later on after knight cc
you have to admit that one of the pawns
will be lost and you could see that
in this position nepo has a clear
advantage what happened later it's
another story there were a few ups and
downs and you could see the ending but
it on the end of the day he managed to
win this game so good start for yanipong
which game you were checking alejandro i
was taking a look at the game between
ivan saric and maxine vasherla graf
because unfortunately for the creation
when it rains it pours again he has a
winning position i saw it in a crazy
position i know you almost want to root
for him in every game because he's had
great positions he's played great chess
but the points are just not coming his
way and in this one not only was he in a
much better position he didn't even
manage to hold it they yvonne played
this very sharp night off and they got
to this position specifically after the
move b5 he had the correct idea to play
knight a5 hit this rook on c4 and then
jump to the c6 square what was he afraid
of he was afraid of rook before and the
weakening of the dark squares he didn't
have to play he didn't want to have to
play b3 and then weaken the entire
diagonal but it's all smoke there is no
actual danger in this position the rook
is just
seven because i stole my move queen c7
yes and i got knight c6 yes and just on
time the queen is blocked from entering
a c3 so this one worked out instead what
does he do he plays the move c3 first
and it looks great because you cannot
play b4 queen takes c4 follows no
counter play but maxime is just an
absolute magician when it comes to
finding counter play plays the movie
three sheds upon a central pawn too so
that when the queen is on e3 it's not
attacking the rook and what happens b4
comes and now there's a real real
counter attack going in the game went
through a lot of wild turnarounds but it
remained more or less equal until the
very end and again this is so sad
because this one they got to this end
game this is a well-known draw and it's
actually not a very difficult draw
either but maxima has kept the pressure
but kept the pressure and has kept his
chances most importantly and a couple of
moves later he's made his cyrex has made
his defense a little bit harder than he
has to be going to c4 was not absolutely
necessary but here was the moment of
truth mark dorothy's book and gay manual
you got to know it you have to attack
the rook here on c5 with the move king
c5 he did not find it he actually went
king d3 which allowed the pawn to
advance to the end of the board and
maxine picked up an important point uh
gotta feel bad for iran maybe two yes
especially after yesterday games today
wow i hope he will do better in the next
ones we certainly hope he recovers guys
an exciting start for round number one
but of course it's just unstoppable
train of magnus carlsen in sagra
absolutely well thank you for those
insights uh anastasia and alejandro and
let's take a look at our next uh
standings first and then our pairings
miro our standings after
change all that much at the very top
yeah so nepo finally climbs to third
spot carlson's leading the pack with
same one and a half points exactly
and uh our pairings what what's going to
be our marquee match-up for this round
11. yeah i like the one at the top what
do you think nepo against mvl after all
yeah we agreed on nepo having a very
successful blitz part exactly it can be
all the magnus magnus magnus we'll keep
him as our uh
our back or plan b yeah mamidiaro faces
dominguez ferruga versus sword that's it
that's it
that's a very important one for both
giants so of course carlson will face
the political clear favorite if you ask
me right and one for rest with white
against ivan
exactly
and uh let's take a look at our
grandchester standings after the
grand chess tour in poland and we are
now in zagreb
uh right so we have uh at the top of the
standings we have a player who is not
playing in zagreb level
ronin 19 gct points but imagine you win
one event like in case of wesley song
yes wins
if he manages to win a long he will add
13 points to he's come yes that's very
much progressively he happens to be in a
competition that's magnus carlson maybe
taking those 13 points he's not on the
list by the way yeah magnus is a wild
card in this tournament but he can you
know he can sneak those points and
fabiano
in third place there mbl was looking for
a very good result he's kind of a bit of
a laggard he needs to really pick up the
pace but he did start with a win and
that's going to be very important and
back over to you christian
well i was just trying to look at this
game of
van forest and magnus and try to figure
things out and see how he could have
improved the van forest that is of
course d6 was a big mistake you can just
simply not it just doesn't fit the
requirements of the position once again
the niton d8 is perfectly controlled by
the pawn on d5 you just played this move
d5 you're controlling both returning
squares for the knights c6 and e6 this
is a perfect position for the pawn on d5
there's absolutely no reason for you to
uh just simply sacrifice with the move
d6 it doesn't improve your cause at all
what does improve your cause would have
been the move a4 finally you're trying
to take as much space on that side as
possible if you do play the move a5 now
i can once again just play move knight
way three knight to c to exchange the
dark square bishops and take advantage
of the badly placed knight on d8 this is
what this position is about and we were
trying to figure things out how do you
get both of your knights into play if
you play the move knight to f6 as black
for example not here because you have to
defend against a5 but let's say knight
to a3 if you do go knight to f6 how do
you get the knight back into play you're
not going to be able to play f6 and then
knight to f7 unless you lose some more
tempes you go d6 then knight to d7 then
f6 the knight is just too much time
spent uh getting this knight back into
place you played move knight to h6 sure
thank you very much i'll take this one
i'll damage your pawn structure and then
your king is going to be extremely
unsafe so i'm not 100 sure what magnus
had prepared in this line is definitely
enough bit line definitely gives white
the advantage but not with the move d6
this was just simply a mistake by a van
forest what do you guys think yeah well
it never panned out i love these
positional sacrifices
when you have a big lead in development
there wasn't that big a lead in
development there especially with the
pawn on c3 i mean you can't go knight c3
knight d5 in a single leap
so it was just bad badly timed
miro what's our special
yes
let's have a look um
well we have an autograph
beautiful some more chests for it yeah
so more chess right and thank you for
watching the 2022 super united
representative blitz croatia enjoyed 20
percent of
all regular priced merchandise including
upper l chess sets tournament
merchandise with the code su
20.
i see the name of anna zatonski there
that kind of stands out so
uh nice uh these uh commemorative boards
of these major events get your piece of
history
very nice 20 off dang
that's that's a good deal yes i don't
have any any chess boards signed by
someone other than yourself yes
i i'm actually a collector i love chess
sets especially this staunton stats i
love these wooden boards and i love
uh getting the autographs of the players
on them
in fact i have a
rather large collection of friends that
kind of raid my
collection and it's a fight for equality
is
i love these uh mementos if you will
especially from these great grand
chester
tournaments it's always nice when
you have these i want to say autographed
moments
where all the players are sitting down
and you bring them your books or your
t-shirts or whatever it is
and you can get the players to autograph
their photos i i love those moments
okay guys so who's stopping madness
uh yeah is it going to be topalov
maybe but uh somebody's got to do it
otherwise it's just
going to be a great fight for the second
place
honestly this is leslie's
still keeping up connection with magnus
putting some pressure from one and a
half points so far but still putting
some pressure on him yeah well so we'll
have a chance to play magnus with white
in the very next round after this one oh
it's going to be a big one and that will
be important and here is our marquee
matchup
as we have a world championship finalist
uh jan with the white side and mbl
and i have to say jan is a completely
different person uh compared to the
first day after the rapids yes i mean he
was just in shambles
picked himself up and right now he's
showing his best self
okay and they're playing a very uh
awkward i want to say grunfeld it's a
hybrid
yeah
yeah because this
instead of knight c6 there was knight e4
is a major line
and okay the players are
there's also this old-fashioned e6 right
which is very popular back in the day
because baroff had made it very popular
in his mat world championship match with
anatoly karpov
and now what do we think with the pawn
on c6
a backward pawn is it going to be this
is their theory yeah they did by far
this is
just
knife h5 knight h5 okay
in general white doesn't get absolutely
nothing out of this so i'm curious to
see what yon has in store bishop to e3
but my first thought was that that move
wasn't playable but uh there is a if i
capture on the d5 with the bishop you
capture twice on d4
you're talking to me
mvl is a grunfeld specialist right and
he's showing that right now he played
the d5 with the knight i would assume
you take on d4 with the pawn right yeah
i was going to take on d5 with the
bishop and hit your rook okay with the
knight
he copies young captures with the knight
but
so is it taking on d4 and if you do take
back i would take back and then play the
move e6 right and then the knight is
somewhat pinned but there will be g4
there will be g4 there's also e4 at
that point so you have some options as
white as well exactly okay so
maybe we start with e6 pay attention to
the names of i mean we still we are
still in the database oh i see d5 so
shock mommy diara yeah i thought i was
wrong but chuck number yaroff played it
against uh martiro's son at the wealth
cup 2021 last time actually it's a world
cup yeah it's not your random online
blitz game that's right world cup uh
game yeah e7 e6 uh that was a little bit
of reflection there that was the move in
that game as well
and knight f4 kind of looks force unless
i'm sacrificing a piece which i don't
believe knight is on the board
now if you take uh it's an exchange
sacrifice i think i can take
capture f5 i don't know
d4 immediately i take on h5 now
kind of ruining the pawn structure and
then i think i have to take the rook
anything else and i'm
i'm not happy
yeah the question would be
how he ruined the pawn structure is
right he did she takes yes and now he
what takes the rook i gotta take the
rock yeah but then queen takes an h4
next move like if is it really too bad
for black um funnily enough i was
actually yeah so you were playing
you could play bishop h3 in the position
with the queen on a8
bishop f4 e5 was bishop f4 any good
because it simply looks like it walks
into you know into the temple tempo yeah
okay at some point
no he never took the rook i was about to
say
at some point you need to take this rook
to justify
the fact that you've traded
a b-pawn
for this pretty menacing looking deep on
i mean
uh h4 h3 and i'm i'm a little worried
for white here i think yeah and vl has
taken the initiative christian what's
your thought no absolutely he is taking
over this game uh nepo is in big trouble
right now i can just simply play the
move e4 and uh try to take even more
space in the center and at some point
one of d3 or e3 is going to come on the
border destroying your uh pawn structure
or creating a very dangerous passport
on d3 is already very very far advanced
and i can also improve my position with
the move that he just played h3 i love
this move uh alpha zero move uh
pawn to h3 keep that king in check all
the time exactly those back ranked
checkmates are a constant reminder that
this pawn on h3 is an awkward one to
deal with bishop to c6 as opposed to
bishop h1 maybe e4 will cut the bishop
out of place so well bishop to c6 is
also aimed to support the b-pawn as well
as to play against rook to e8 because we
were discussing this avalanche in the
center e4 followed by e3 now without the
work on e8 it's very difficult to do e4
followed by e3
okay queen a4
uh
that was like
through the magic of chess this queen
went from d1 to c6 in a single leap
how it feels like white improved his
position yeah that trait of bishops
actually
feels like this white queen is suddenly
doing getting something
yeah yeoman's work
and
you you really want to just simply
capture that pawn on h3 queen to d7
defends upon
like that move rook to c5
intimating that
the open file is a good one
are we
worried about the pawn on a2 or not
moves like
rook a6 and
c6
queen e6 was already played
i was a little bit well okay a4
could be matt was queen a2 nevertheless
yes exactly that pawn the b3 therefore
so queen from f3 guards
by the way guys just give you an update
it seems like wesley saw is actually uh
losing
against fiorugia and magnus is uh
beating so far to paulo
okay
definitely having a much better position
so magnus might be winning his seventh
game in a row that's a car one all right
that's the car you wanna we're talking
about
referring to
to uh fabiano's great result in the
sinkhole cup where he won seven in a row
uh rook a6 that kind of provokes bishop
c whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
just
remind that you have a king yourself
right and the open g file and he says i
don't care about my king right pick up
some pawns okay do we
no this
bishop bishop f before no threat
[ __ ] yeah
i have f6 exactly
isn't it time that one of these pawns
starts uh
going why not uh d5
department d3
d3 i'm gonna go for it d3 let's go on
the board right
and again mbl is thinking that bishop e5
is going to be met by f6
i mean whenever these pieces around the
king you start thinking about moves like
rook g7 so bishop
bishop e5 f6
be met with queen to h6 but does that
improve my cause at all probably not
right
rook f7
at the end of that line rook g4 radio
electric g4 idea so that
okay maybe i'm threatening queen g5 i'm
certainly threatening bishop h6 right
right and sometimes maybe even h3 pawn
so let's go hf5 now f5
now that
yeah this is what he's planning to do
you know he's done it and now for g6
queen g6 and
you're
okay with that game
he says no no
interesting but the rook on h4 makes
this kind of woeful impression uh
at the same time bishop f6 is always
going to be met by h6 so that is true
the question is
okay but rook to d8 is going for
let's get behind the passer
not only that but also defending against
the check on d5 there is a pin
you can't play d2 right away
in fact you can wait a second nepo just
blundered it d2 is possible whoa whoa
c6
rooks are hanging everywhere that was a
terrible way of doing this
i can take this rook i can take this
rook but you were going to make no no i
mean i thought the threat was so obvious
i made this rook v8 and yet nepal played
bishop c7 as if it was uh so quick
queen takes d1 and you can't take right
you would take the queen and
make it and then yeah so you make a
queen i take it
like yes so now you know
he could have taken on h3 that would i
can also go queen c6 now i think that
might be a big problem no but i was
saying instead of taking the rook on d8
he could have taken on h3
first
threatening the queen
that would have been an important tempo
the queen would have had to drop back
well perhaps
so
rook takes h3 was a huge miss i think
you would still be losing material now
if i take the pawn yes queen h1
absolutely
absolutely no i just wanted to you to
mention you mentioned that yeah yeah he
mentioned it already that rook takes h3
queen h1 is a showstopper
nice queen sacrifice and if you go f3
bishop d4 right yeah and that finishes
the game as well
and he's done f3 he's done f3 but you're
actually going to wait for something
even more pretty than bishop to d4
you're losing the rook on h4 as well as
the queen's v8
now you'll be able to take now quincy
two wins right
c6 to c2 i like c6 to c2 white has no
checks
uh well strictly only move to stop
checkmate which is rook h3 and then
bishop d4
that's a beautiful finish very uh pretty
finished
yeah wow what a game
nice nice
magnus guys okay let's jump to uh oh my
goodness magnus is losing no magnus is
in a huge trouble right
so he's even a pawn up right he's a porn
up sound he's born up but his knights
are tied down to one another black has
like a fantastic
active position
so what was the tzugswang right the the
two bishops said to g3 is coming
that
vessel and topolof has made a career
from
czech that's such a check
bishop yeah okay i think this is really
his position yeah it feels like the
beautiful technique here
and there goes the pawn and bishop to c1
bishop to c1 sets up king g3 i like
bishops versus one because
knight d4 yeah but now those knights are
jumping but you can take and the knight
g3 king g3 king g3 yeah just going in
yeah
that one yeah i think g3 would have won
right i mean he was afraid of losing the
bishop perhaps yes but it would have won
just just take the g2 pawn truly
now it's much more okay you don't have
king e3s the problem and by the way
well another big result yeah beaten
wesley so furuja wins against wesley so
everyone is beating everybody
knight a7 king f4 knight a6
and will this bishop be able to
sacrifice it's 95 king f4 doesn't really
help because knight d5 is there right
and you're forced to go back
you're forced to go back so
i believe no but i believe white is very
happy with the draw
no
no magnus has to be happy with the draw
right well he's not he's not he's
clearly not he's not bishop a7 to avoid
knocking it b2 g4 ah but the his point
is the a6 pawn a6 pawn is not going away
yeah okay
i i guess uh
why did he play h3 yeah just keep the
key in here
i don't think you can lose this one
right well wow you could have played the
you can't but no no no drop draw okay
uh but what a miss by topalov right wow
definitely and we have a remaining game
shakriar
versus lanier dominguez and what do we
think about this one
also uh
quite confusing at the moment
what are the clock times of these
players
and even seconds right and this is one
of those games that magnus was
mentioning that he was winning them but
they could easily have gone against him
and this is also one of those where
three results are possible
was played with how many seconds on the
clock well now you've got to make one
sec check bishop e4 key no
wait a second no wait a second winning
who's winning no but no no yeah
he's gonna give checks
that was
that was caught
yeah and he shakes his head what kind of
move was bishop e4 discovered check he
could have played bishop h3 discovery
had taken the pawn yeah
okay you can he can promote it as well
right
yeah
and
okay what a what the fight
fight
79 moves or something yeah
a very very very funny moment but boy
the results uh
we think that vessel and topolof could
have easily
won but because of the draw magnus saved
this draw he's got a two-point lead yeah
he extends his lead
and uh let's just jump to nepo's blunder
right here
he
he played the move bishop c7
the bishop was actually defending
guarding the d2 square the one would
have been better
three would have been better yeah but
bishop c7 d2 and that was it yeah queen
is hanging rook is hanging
and d1 is uh coming as well not only
that but the queen on f3 was nicely
protecting that diagonal g2 to c6 coming
as well hitting the bishop on c7 hitting
the pawn everything is is is just in uh
in the wrong spot there there's blitz
for you christian
what a fun game but guys let's take a
look at what happened in the furuja
versus wesley games yeah we have seen
that that one and first took down wesley
in uh exemplary fashion let's take a
look d4 knight to f6 c4 knight to c3 and
we get this nimzo which is becoming very
popular with the move e3 and after that
bishop to d3 or bishop to d2 wesley so
actually with the white pieces is also
playing this variation bishop to d2 a3
the bishop drops back to e7 and this is
the critical moment right now uh in my
opinion because finally we got the
hanging pawns and this is what gives
white a strategical edge in this
position it's very difficult to find for
black away to create the initiative and
this is exactly what wesley struggled
with as well in this game and i have a
clear plan as uh white i'm going to open
up the files for my rooks i'm going to
centralize this root put it on d1 get
the knight to f4 and just simply target
these two pawns c5 and d5 strategically
i'm going to have a very comfortable
play as white and virus i knew it rook
to b8 rook to d1 and this is exactly
what wesley is doing in this game as
well he also missed the fact that yes
there's a pawn on h7 and you should
probably defend it he did not he played
the move knight to a5 and after bishop
to h7
not only that you're losing some pawns
in the center the pawn on d5
specifically but also your king becomes
extremely weak and well unfortunately
for him nothing could have saved him
after that beautiful sacrifice bishop
takes g6 and after knight to e5 you just
simply don't have enough pieces around
your king i'm going to take my piece
back with dividends because i also have
three pawns extra in the position this
is it game over and wesley is losing his
second game of the tournament quite
impressive by ali reza
van forest also a big victory against
asaris to keep him uh in contention not
within striking distance but he's
definitely keeping contact with that
third and uh second position let's see
how he got the win e4 c5 knight to uh d4
and this early bishop to c4 which
transposed into a sawzin later on knight
to c3 knight to c6
and a funny moment came at this point
after a5 bishop to f1 queen to c7 check
this move out bishop to a7 i think he
wanted to uh play bishop to b6 and he
just like moved it one step uh further
than anticipated it makes no sense right
why would you play bishop to a7 and he
realized that later on and he played
bishop to b6 okay let me get back to b6
where i wanted to put that bishop first
still white with a slight slight edge in
the position g3 setting up this pressure
on the long diagonal on the weaknesses
in black's position that is the pawn on
b7 and with an open center like this we
definitely prefer the bishop over the
knight
rook to c5 bishop to g2 c3 h5 black is
trying to create something on the king
side at the same time i really like this
move rook to a for setting up this idea
of rook to b4 uh attacked the pawn on b7
but also keeping an eye on the king side
potentially look to h4 and create some
attacks against the king and at this
point this end game was just simply much
better for white and he went on to win
knight to d5 and after bishop takes d5
g6 was a mistake queen to e7 would have
finished the game instantaneously
setting up this pressure on the seventh
rank rook to b7 followed by g6 the same
idea beautiful game uh by van forest and
guys in zagreb what games did you have
your eyes on
well thank you christian we had our eyes
on actually the two draws that we have
in today's round but they were very
fighting draws anastasia take us through
yours uh you were checking the ending of
the game between mamedyarov and
dominguez and actually i must tell you i
was in the playing hall at this moment
and all players were following magnus
carlson just finished his game and he
was standing there and all of them
started to laugh especially at the
moment when bishop before was played in
the board my mijera was laughing himself
magnus was laughing i mean everybody
realized i mean that it just uh the kind
of plunder right i mean just take my
bishop yes so but before that i mean it
was of course a pretty tense theoretical
battle in english opening and
definitely players knew a lot
and then um after
after they exchanged all the pieces more
or less i mean the board
actually they had very very interesting
ending i mean it's knight against bishop
to rooks and look what happened actually
after e4 this knight is on f3 we know
that if the knight comes on the third or
sixth rank it's it cannot be bad but
look uh how maybe djerov first of all
got rid of this knight he played this
bishop g4 telling him to go away and
then arrested the rook on the eighth by
playing bishop said and now yes actually
now if you play b6 then bishop b7
threatening e4 pawn and rook a8 follows
so after that i mean black had to play
move rugby three and then we gave i mean
this ending i mean really we can analyze
it forever there were so many ups and
downs uh downs but what happened clearly
that after some unnecessary moves we got
to this position and you can see when
from from where the king stands we can
understand that this position is better
for white i mean white if he managed to
play e5 a certain point he will do
really great so but still you had to
play very precisely don't forget to we
have blitz event so at the same so many
many things were happening i mean 93
maybe was unnecessary moving tonight
from the center because actually nobody
was threatening so this ending was
really really interesting let's go maybe
to one of those moments when critical
moments when white played this move
bishop f5 uh once again he probably had
to try to get rid of this knight yes and
play sounds like or move the king
forward like king d5 and then actually
black has no poses no moves right
yes either way like in the knight d3
maybe like bishop f5 now you know to
make sure first that the knight goes out
from here i mean there were some many
many details but what happened we could
see at the end i mean it was really
crazy and uh intense yes what about you
alejandro which game you were looking i
had my eyes on the world champion of
course he's the leader of the tournament
he was playing against vessel into polov
and you think
magnus in shape with white against
vaseline
people are not even watching this game
but lo and behold it was actually magnus
that saved this one the opening started
exactly how you would expect magnus with
a blistering start won a pawn as early
as move 12 in an end game already look
at this a sicilian end game i took the
pawn on d6 basically for free and well
people started to lose interest in the
game they started to look at the other
games we had this fantastic battle with
the two queens so a lot of things to see
and then as the games progressed things
got more and more and more complicated
for magnus until i believe he started
overestimating this position we got this
position with the two bishops against
the two knights but an extra pawn for
white it looks like white still has the
advantage but actually you have to be a
little bit careful the two bishops are
very powerful and this structure
with
e4 f3 g2 and h3 are all on light squares
which means that the penetration of the
king is possible via the dark squares
and that's exactly what happened look at
this king race into the position after a
couple of traits of the pawns the
computer already thinks that black is
winning in this position despite the
fact that white is up upon king e5 boom
king f4 and here at this point you can
even continue with the move king g3
there's nothing stopping topalov from
going in and his refusal to go king g3
in this position and in a later position
let me show you is what cost him the
half point because wrestling had this
wrapped up and ready to go check it out
despite the fact again that he's down a
pawn these bishops are absolutely
dominant bishop b3 perhaps not the best
move but take a look at this instance
right here let's fast forward a little
bit he got his pawn back and here you
have a choice you can take on e4 which
is a pawn but you can also just go king
g3 yes there is a knight fork knight e2
check picks up the bishop who cares
about the bishop king takes g2 knight
takes c1 you can even take on h3 the
move g4 of course wins but king takes h3
is the cleaner version this pawns simply
promote no way that a knight alone is
going to stop them and that'll be an
easy victory vessel also had an extra
minute compared to magnus carlsen and at
this moment you know chess players
they're like vultures the moment that
you see the world champion losing they
started to crowd around his board you
saw alireza finish his game started to
look at magnus's board wesley finishes
game started to look at magnus's board
when forest had finished early he just
stayed there and watched the entire time
until magnus was finished but what a
save by magnus because after knight
takes e6 bishop e3 was a decisive
mistake
not losing the full point but losing the
half point because after knight c7 black
is getting a little bit of trouble
because knight takes a6 is coming there
is a pass b pawn and suddenly it's a two
result it's a three result game actually
uh but the game finished with its
logical conclusion in a draw after the
pawns were simply traded off and of
course one pawn alone is simply not
going to win this one a little bit lucky
for magnus carlsen but also lucky the
fact that his closest rivals are not
doing so well wesley losing to alireza
means that it's a two point advantage
for the world champion in zagreb it's
just becoming bigger and bigger seven
rounds to go i don't think anybody's
going to come close to touching magnus
in this tournament absolutely actually i
was recording the video while all the
players were gathering around the game
between magnus and whistling so you can
watch them in instagram absolutely
follow us on instagram we're gonna take
a short commercial break we'll be right
back with round number three from the
westin zagreb
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after two rounds of blitz uh these are
our current standings miro yeah well it
seems everything goes magnus's way and
the moment when he slowed down even more
so did his uh his rivals right so wesley
loses
young nepal loses and it's it's two
points between wesley and magnus and i
think yeah that's that's the big game
for wesley we kept talking how many more
rounds left but it's not that many and
maybe there's the last chance to stop
magnus by winning the game against him
that's the game we'll be following
closely wesley saw against magnus carson
they have started
uh whoa is it the scotch defense sure it
looks like four knights d4 is yeah
or whatever yes wesley wants to stop
magnus this is it
yeah he's got it he needs to win he
needs a result no question about it and
with this move castles
it's basically not wait is this
the
well i mean i think it was a very
deliberate pawn sacrifice no no
i meant wesley himself he left the chair
which is not very often
in blitz you know i think he just put
the jacket away yeah bishop
still sporting his own with all this
sweatshirt there's all this excitement
that we were talking about this game i'm
afraid it's one of the very yucky ones
right
yeah this is the game of karjakin that
he won
with the white pieces yeah not only that
kavyakin won against vidit and this is
kind of what gave birth to this
variation right but then there were
quite a few games and i believe by now
black people
bit surprising right for wesley
as white so break it down
i mean obviously it's a very tepid
position
uh dry ending but wesley is for choice
and
if i
if i had the move rook b8 it would be
game over but unfortunately there's a
checkmate so all i have to do is
is sidestep the back rank mate and
threaten rook b8 right so it's either f3
or rage three something like that and
you're threatening rook b8 yeah h4 in
fact and uh
h3 or f3
and again uh the mo i'm threatening rp8
wins
so i assume bishop has the oh king of
fate yeah king of faith is possible in
fact okay
and then rook a8 a6
okay then you can't move uh king to d6
bishop b7 yeah you're right then i can't
move so
wait a minute
no no no no no no no but if you go rook
b8 king e7 rook a8 i have bishop d7
right
bishop bishop to d7 absolutely right and
then you will have to trade that i trade
everything in fact i would have to do
and i think i'm okay with that
absolutely
so rook b8 king e7
um
magnus doesn't seem bothered at all no
no in fact it looks he's pretty happy
with his position that's exactly what
i'm saying i mean this line it was
considered to be a little bit tricky if
black doesn't know it but by now they've
already figured out what
the exact news order there taking a
different approach instead of going for
the pin on the eighth rank
uh maybe a little oscillation along the
third
yeah
okay
so this is the magnus board but let's
contract
contrast it with the uh
okay
a board full of pieces on one side of
the table
yeah yeah i have you know the polyphone
forest uh open on my screen and
they've only they've only exchanged one
couple of pawns i tell you what i mean
this is a dry ending for us let's go and
find where some action is take us miro
what
where would you like to take us
uh yeah let me see dominguez ferruja
well i don't know a lot of lots of stuff
on the part of the uh
okay we just saw this last move queen d3
by mvl eyeballing this pawn on a6 this
looks like a very it comes comes from a
very topical line of the ruling lopez
with uh bishop c5 and uh
white
white's playing for the pawn
bishop takes a6 what a shack what uh
christian what does shakriar have to do
that is a good question to be honest i
wasn't watching that
as
much
it does seem like white is definitely
nursing a slight advantage
but you can counter this idea of bishop
takes a6 maybe with creating your own
target on d4 so you have to take on d4
first
take on d take on d4 take on d4 and
maybe you can continue that with c5
taking advantage of the fact that there
is a pin you cannot yeah there is no d5
there is no
it's still white who is for choice
but once you play the move c5 i mean
that bishop on a7 is crying and he did
take one take on d4 very next move
perhaps right i will take on d4 yes
take takes
yes it's happening if you play c5 i'll
play e5 you want to play e5 and then
what if i take back yeah you take
everything and
that bishop on a7 so i've got a check
yes he's a man of culture
i really like this because i really like
this this bishop on a7 is really bugging
me okay c5 is a challenging move but uh
if it if it doesn't pan out
it's that bishop on on a7 is toast well
the thing is since you've captured on d4
i think you have to go for c5 because
you're kind of committed right
okay knight h4
but this we can we can simply trade it
seriously well it seems like e pawn is
uh
i mean the desirable bishop e3 so we can
ends up just leaving the e pawn on pre
but can you can you take the e pawn
though
i beg your pardon uh can you take the
e4 pawn off the bish p3 i'm not so sure
yes because queen takes its bishop d2
you are running to or something of that
nature or even yeah
okay and
rook takes i'm afraid bishop g5 might
work bishop g5 yeah so if rook that
bishop e3 rook takes e4 and even bishop
g5 might work well i'd love i mean the
problem with bishop takes a6 and
capturing that
is that the d4 pawn is hanging which is
why i want to play bishop e3 if it turns
out the e pawn is untouchable
he has played rook eight rook a2
which is e2 perhaps yeah but that slows
him down quite a bit exactly
well let's just uh return to our marquee
matchup between wesley and uh magnus
because
well maybe maglin magnus
was for choice i mean
he picked up the pawn on h4 wait now
he's probably going to pick up the c
pawn how did that happen so when we left
it we thought it was so dry
there was nothing to discuss it's the
magnus magic
yeah well he captured the h4
he sure did
and rook a8 look you should still be
able to make a draw in this position i
understand once you take on c2 we
exchange that and the three versus two
inside am i kind of forced to take h5
like this just go h5 yeah he goes get
rid of whatever it was on the board yeah
yeah a little fluff
but h4 or
you know
kind of
at some point
right
we should be three and four is the trade
of those bishops
well indeed the whole the whole plan of
rook a8 is based on the idea
that we're going to rush the april but
rook on a8 isn't it kind of an unlucky
piece because uh okay he goes with the
check i was thinking bishop b3 then h4
check happens and you can't go to f3
because bishop check take the rook
right so therefore he starts with a
check on e8 okay
king
f6 i wonder
king f6 bishop b3
yeah and i still want to come with a guy
like h4 shack
perhaps okay we'll see
bishop c3 bishop to b3 seems pretty
straightforward
now if you do play h4 check and i move
my king let's say to h2 i've given
rook e2
to as a way of protecting the pawn on
and
okay for now magnus simply plays rook c5
not a
strange move to my eyes it doesn't
you didn't you didn't play h4 and with
the check and
you didn't give a check on c3 and trying
to pin the wind upon
so i have rookie 2 as well as a4 yeah i
think a4 should be good enough right for
a draw yeah
give to c2 pawn yet and eventually
exchange your past pawn for black c7
pawn i'm just thinking rookie too i'm
slightly better as white as what
i'm the one with the past pawn but it's
not going too far right with your rook
being no need to but like
magnum is going to go g5 rook e1 well
the problem is right now you're starting
to see ghosts as white and that is the
problem you also have only 55 seconds
can i can i take the c to pawn by the
way you can you have rook g5 at the ux
e1 yeah rook
i have missed rook g5 by the way i think
i'm not sure
wesley hasn't either although again
that's a draw yeah three versus two
uh easy draw
for white
that rook
e1 strange move rookie two defending the
pawn
well the thing is
if you do want to pick up a pawn
probably now is the time
just take on c2 and play that end game
he's done it rook c1 i expect
or yeah
where do you put the king now
you probably hide it on h2 right yeah
probably go to h2
all right and then
magnus trades and we will end up in
three verses i don't know he has c5 but
c5 c4 rook rook c for group four
can't really avoid the trade yeah
f3 f3
or king g1 if you want to be super safe
f3 is
pretty safe
he wasn't sure he really wasn't sure
uh
i was that was kind of a funny moment
there uh by wesley yeah okay i don't
think wesley unless something like crazy
happens there this should be a complete
draw let's go back to which game that we
kind of put our
little action
well i i want to say let's go back to
napo versus saric saris versus nebo in
that regard because nepal might be
cutting the lead
if he wins this one
not by much half a point but still
that's
that's an improvement
ivan sarich with the white pieces
gosh this looks like another one of
those petrov defenses that has gone
swimmingly well by the way that last
move was made with one second on the
clock
quite impressive uh when is that king on
the f5 yeah one is important right
and rook a one okay one there's gonna be
a pawn with chuck key f3 do you have any
traction
yeah so that's the question i mean yeah
okay we capture rook
e6 yeah back to
you can e6
bishop e7 it feels a bit awkward but
yeah king d7 is fine
and now the bishop defends the a pawn so
we are connected
we actually have two extra pawns right
and we're keeping both of
wow how could you not play a2 there why
not
a2 that's that's a good question
wow
he likes this one he simply likes this
one
enough yeah good enough
ali razor alireza wins against
yes with the black piece
b says wesley back to wesley
and magnus
and now instead of three versus two two
versus one beautiful f pawn on f3 not in
pawn on h3
if the pawn was on h3 some small chances
with the pawn on f3 no chances no
chances
f5
kind of a strange move why don't you pin
the pawn there
yeah kind of allowing f5 even though
it's still a draw but yeah you kind of
yeah allow your opponent to improve a
little bit yeah yeah draw anyway draw a
grid and one remaining game
you jordan van forest uh jordan won four
is against the pollock yeah that's a
crazy game i kept an eye on from time to
queen queen black has a queen no white
has a queen black has the knight and
three
the moment you play
f3
i go queen e4 what
mate
king h3 queen h1 that's a win for apollo
3
yeah that's a beautiful checkmate
win photopolyps which once again
improves magnus's chances so he helped
yes wesley saw for a draw himself
exactly then
jordan who was in the third position he
loses
yeah magnus seems unstoppable yes yeah
well just by making those draws he's
actually improving
uh as uh he has a two
point lead with three games already in
the history book six
six more to go to to play yeah and
christian what games caught your eye
well let's take a look at how that game
between mvl and mamadiaro finished we
left it off at this point c5 was the
move that we were considering you have
to do something about this weakness on
a6 you're going to lose it most likely
you need to create some sort of counter
chances in the position and this was
probably the only way to do so he did
not uh do that he played the move knight
to h4 but unfortunately once again
you're not solving your problem which is
the pawn on a6 you're going to lose that
and if you don't have something to show
for it well you're just simply going to
be a pawn up upon down and what upon
this a pawn is going to go down the
board especially after bishop to e3 and
the exchange of the dark square bishop
so let's see how this game progressed uh
bishop to c3 rook take c2 we exchange or
no problem for white this exchanges
definitely help my cause c6 a6 this is
exactly what he was doing exchange the
pawns on the cnd file so that after
bishop to d4 black doesn't have the move
c5 to avoid the exchange of the dark
square bishop and this is exactly what
happened
later on actually he didn't even need
that anymore he used the fact that the
background is extremely weak coupled
with the fact that the bishop is
attacking the square h8 there is a
checkmate coming and there is no way to
defend against it beautiful and precise
win by mvl and also dominguez versus
firuja well this game was pretty wild
dominguez definitely built up an
advantage out of the opening it was a
real lopez but he was uh getting a lot
of space on the queen side and i really
liked what he was doing blocking this
pawn on d7 with
this thorn in black's position the pawn
on c5 unfortunately for him they got to
this point and he was slowly slowly
improving his position building up uh
but unfortunately at this point he made
a huge mistake check this out
knight to e4 rook to f8 and king to h2
well this just loses a piece in one move
bishop takes e4 would have finished the
game you take back with the queen i take
back and you just played king to h2 so
the [ __ ] pawn f2 is no longer protected
thank you very much gift me uh the piece
and that's a piece up and just a winning
position he missed it no he missed it he
did not play bishop takes e4 gave
dominguez another chance to build up his
advantage and still to be preferred
dominguez but unfortunately you took the
pawn at the wrong time the timing is not
correct and you allow the black queen to
get
infiltrate around the white king not
only that but f3 is coming with
devastating consequences as well and
this is exactly what happened king to g1
was the last moment to try to save this
game but still the position after f3
queen to d2 it is only black that can be
better in the position after king to h1
f3 you're actually completely losing
because also f2 is coming in the
position and uh this is how the game
ended f2 rook to e1 queen to c4
defending the queen i only need to bring
the queen to attack if you play a6 i
will take take queen to e1 and the game
is over dominguez resigns first picks up
his second win in uh this day and guys
in zagreb what do you have
thank you christian well we had a couple
of interesting games here as well
anastasia which one did you have your
eye on i was checking the game between
ivan saric and yanni pomney poor ivan
suffering so much in this tournament
already five games he lost in a row if
we consider also yesterday games um we
you you check the the end of the action
uh but um i was checking from the
beginning and it was pitcher of defense
and um everything went smoothly until uh
really this moment i mean more or less
they got this moral sequel ending how
can you lose it it looks so dead drawn i
mean three versus threes no pieces left
on the board what happened yes actually
if you want to study endings especially
in petrov you should definitely check
the games of jan because he is doing
some miracles today and look he played
this b5 very bit aggressive move trying
maybe to get some make some weaknesses
on the queen side and then after a
couple of exchanges um pushing the bones
here there i would like to go to the
moment actually when all this started
like again nothing crazy is happening
right now after move a3 um here white
could uh
take on a3 actually just exchange the
spawn or just actually keep quiet you
know because what black wants just to
take on b2 so bishop beto will follow so
nothing crazy stills but uh ivan played
b4 probably hoping to create also some
control play there are some chances
maybe thinking that a3 pawn is weak or
something like that but look what ivan
what actually jan did after so he played
rook f3 and then suddenly king goes to
b5 and you cannot actually protect the
pawn both of them on b4 and f2 so what
happened just had bishop
exactly
so after rook d3 i mean after all these
moves i mean black just ended up with
extra pawn and the result was never in
the doubt
ivan was trying to do something he
played like rook b1 um but actually you
know what happened it was funny he
didn't really threaten to play rook b1
and bishop d2 because bishop was pinned
so probably black would just keep this
rook maybe on h3 something like that uh
anyway jan played it perfectly i mean he
didn't give chances and won
the point
well another one that won their full
point is vaseline topple off he was
playing against the original van forest
and it was a wild one perhaps jordan
came into the game saying look i am
black but i'm playing against vesseling
he's not doing so well can i use this
opportunity to try to catch the leaders
remember that he is a lot behind magnus
carlsen but not so far behind the
certain wesley saw there was only half
point difference between these two
players going into this round but what
happened vaseline said hey remember i
was world champion at some point you
just can't play whatever against me and
wrestling played a great game uh let me
put you on the key moment here
as we had this very strange structure
you can see that the white pieces have
control over the center wide because of
these pawns e3 and d4 giving him an
excellent chance to expand and go
forward and that's exactly what he did
starting with the push d5 it looks a
little scary on the king side queen on
f6 the knight on g4 there's a big hole
on f3 that you want to see this knight
jump into but you just don't have the
time for it the bishop will retreat also
the bishop is hanging at the moment and
take a look at this
in the position after the move d6
jordan said you know what let's go for
it sacrificed a queen
not necessary he could have just played
the move queen d7 the game would have
continued but he went full on aggressive
queen takes e4 bishop takes e4 knight
takes e4 he must have thought that the
move 95 to f3 coupled with the bishop on
b7 was going to give him counter chances
but this is all just an illusion topalov
played this very very well kept this
under control and in the very end he
actually to follow that is messed up
this position a little bit you can see
that
they eventually got to this end game
king g2 was quite an unnecessary move
you can just go queen c6 immediately but
in this position check out the stack the
group d2 check forcing the trade here on
d2 takes has to shed the rook but
you still have that extra past pawn on
a3 and this is the key to victory for
white in this position yes black got
basically all of his material back
knight on a rook against the queen is
usually not so terrible but
unfortunately this pawn on a3 too strong
and this cost the rook actually it was a
mate's threat
immediately as soon as the pawn on f5k
he immediately threw his king to f4
there was no hesitation on that one but
he did seem very confused in this end
game check it out after he picked up the
rook i thought okay jordan is going to
resign at some point very soon but
actually it was not so clear at some
point he got this structure with three
pawns and a knight against the queen and
i don't even know if you can win against
this i think the table base is actually
saying it's winning by force but do it
in a blitz game good luck uh jordan made
uh vaseline stopov a little bit easier
with this blunder queen f7 uh king f5
queen f7 check king g4 and now after
queen e6 check he got completely stuck
because after knight f5 queen d7 he
realized that his plan idea to move the
pawn forward with the move h4 simply
runs into queen d1 check and that is a
checkmate in two as king h3 queen h1
check king g4 queen f3 is the end of the
game wesleyan picks up a big point but
it's a bigger point for magnus because
his rivals they keep not getting those
full points and people are surging
battle for second place no battle for
first one here yeah what a game actually
yeah congratulations to celine he's
doing really well he's just trying
enjoying himself i think playing those
games draw guys magnus and then a victor
against jordan van forest i mean not
that bad at start for the day here for
vaseline guys back to the studio we
still have six rounds of blitz here in
zagreb
thank you anastasia alejandro i see that
queen takes e4 by
um jordan i think medina
sacrificing a queen for two pieces let's
take a look at our standings mira who's
on top who's on top it's magnus carlsen
once again yes i say you got to be the
world champion right to go away with
making draws and only extending your
lead right exactly wesley's second but
nepo is hovering and he kind of leap
frogs back and forth with jordan van
forest man that is a huge tie we own 17
points the frenchman i don't really
believe in them catching up with magnus
carlsen but even wesley saw is not
you know too guaranteed yeah two points
a big big fight for uh the podium and
here it is the blitz bearings for round
thirteen mirror so two frenchmen playing
each other ferruja against mbl monsters
nepal carlson will have white against
dominguez one for rest with white
against wesley
let's make that our marquee match up we
haven't seen much of jordan in uh wesley
and as you were about to finish so
follow against saurage yes
and of course the summer of chess
continues here in saint louis mural yeah
so well
as a part of gct events there will be
saint louis rapid and blitz very nice
the last classical event of gct which is
syncfield cup and our gc2e tour ends
with the same field cup of course
and then the fish are random
champion showdown chess 960 or chess 9lx
as we say starts the day after
cups so it's non-stop chess activity in
saint louis yeah
and over to you uh chris
well uh i was actually looking through
uh some games and trying to figure out
uh some ideas and to be honest i got to
this point yes in this game between
magnus carlsen and uh wesley so and i
just wanted to point out the fact that
how important uh rook and games are to
know especially at the beginner's level
because you get very often in this type
of situations and you have to be in a
full
control right in the position to
equalize the game and make a draw with
two versus three you have to know this
type of end game is extremely extremely
important but guys who's going to stop
magnus carlsen once again i'm asking you
and there are six rounds to play two
points advantage that's a huge advantage
and i can only think of maybe it's this
is a reference that not of a lot of the
young guns are going to recognize uh the
mask somebody stopped me
you guys know that
uh from uh the map jam carry yes
somebody stopped me that's magnus right
now
nice nice indeed
remember larry bird a famous uh nba uh
player uh shoots like three in a row
bang bang bang and as he's going up the
court he turns to the
coach of the other team and he says
coach you got anybody on your bench who
can
guard me coach looks down and says no
who's going to stop my magnus magnus
yeah
maybe only magnus himself uh jordan then
forrest he's hanging around uh he's
he kind of said well i'm not the
greatest blitz player
and maybe that's true but still he's
he's in the thick of things he's done
he's done very well already
if we look at the standings uh actually
almost nobody can uh pick up the pace
and catch van forest in sixth position
so the top six are almost guaranteed
that they will end up in the top six
because the lanier who is in seventh
position is four points bigger yeah what
the gap yeah no nobody is going to catch
van forest right
well i mean he'll be very pleased to be
in such illustrious company
as the top six no question about that
oh that's
i mean usually it's a lonely job but uh
this is unusual nepo
i've seen him kind of arriving late
last seconds right right then the rounds
announced i mean you may start the clock
and then nep was dropping
exactly now he's so now he's interested
if not the first to arrive yeah yeah now
he's into it i mean again that day one
where with the bombshell announcement
by magnus carlson abdicating
his world championship title that threw
everybody off including magnus i think
and now napo he seems to
[Music]
enjoy the moment yes magnus
confident cool calm collected ready
for another one
and dominguez
and he's going to be the man to try
in front of magnus
again as magnus came into this event he
was the fourth
on the live rating list for blitz
players
his performance has been such
that he's leapfrogged past
uh hikaru nakamura to now be number one
in the world in the live blitz ratings
as well
um although he's kind of slowed down
just a little bit well slowed down a
little bit but still it's not two out of
three today it's not uh well the result
was which you lose yeah do any rating
points right right but when you're 20 60
you'd be amazed what's he's winning uh
28 rating points right now uh this is he
is in front yeah that's
six points ahead of hikaru nakamura
but that means any single loss could
cost him uh the first yes
and there we do see a handshake by the
way between wesley
and and actually it's quite an
interesting uh log jam at the top is
aronian and hikaru who have the exact
same rating 28.50 oh my
as uh the game is underway uh queen's
gambit accepted
uh wesley
what he wants to be
super super super safe and solid
he's probably one of the best queens
gambit accepted players i've seen in my
career i it's something i like to play
also as black but i have to say wesley
has neutralized
the world's best players and very
standard so far
when i had this position as white i
often play p2 b3 and old i t idea of
akiva
uh rubitstein queen e2 is very standard
bishop b3 and bishop d3 also the most
popular most rookie one
less so key one knight to c6 rookie one
i'm not
usually the rook is sliding to d1
this intimates i want to play for e4 but
how are you going to do that could it be
that it's e4 next move no not knight c3
he went knight c3
yeah
okay that that's now we can see a queen
trade and then the move rookie one did
we just lose
a tempo we went bishop e7 takes c5
yes
even steven you're right but after the
move bishop e2 sorry guys uh again uh
for me
this is pretty stale stuff here
executive decision yeah
are we moving where where would you like
to take us let's go to magnus i mean
mostly any other game it's more exciting
than this one of us well i was going to
say the frenchman or uh yeah frenchman
playing something where are you magnus
oh it's true we need to see him uh
suffer a little bit we what was the old
one
what was the opening it was a king kong
with d3
so this is how you fill a door
but wait a minute i'm thinking of yobaba
he's been experimenting 3d33 with these
uh reverse philadelphia as well
as we heard
also plays this
well it's kind of frightening when you
have a world champion like magnus that
takes
uh
favorite systems from other players and
improves upon them
you feel kind of awkward ah i like this
move by linear bishop d7 he instantly
wants to play queen c8 while the pawn
on f2
doesn't allow you to play the convenient
move king h2 i like bishop d7
saying to magnus okay
uh what are you going to do so what's
good about white's position can you tell
me yes
um
the flexibility
you that that you can play for d3 d4
on your own uh agenda i want to say uh
right now this knight on c6 it doesn't
really usually square yeah
restricted by the c3 pawn yeah but even
is it time to go d5
even because the yes i wanted to say
because even if you maneuver the knight
to g3
it's not
yeah it's a g6 it doesn't do much so i
would say it's the flexibility but
that's about it i like your move very
much d5 he's going for an attack on the
queen side b5 just trying to get as much
space as possible yeah makes sense
really i would have played d5 and maybe
i would have played it uh probably that
was the exact moment i would have played
it
because i'm thinking that from white's
point of view
white would
encourage the trade of bishops bishop
takes knight takes
you're going to be playing for rook d1
knight h4
and eventually either f4 or d4 again
this knight on c6 is
maybe in the way of c5
uh b4
yeah b4 is one of the possible moves i
like that i would
i would like to encourage that
b4 was the idea to play a treat
exactly
so he has played knight
knight to e7 again prepping c5 on a good
day and
maybe
well just putting the
does he knight
d4 right now i was wondering
e4 pawn right so oh you you yeah you
mean i take it i mean if you take
probably not it takes yes
knight to h4 okay knight h4 that's what
magnus did right right he's uh trying to
go to f5 or perhaps just simply to push
f4
f4 d4 yeah f4 d4 yes
these are the two moves
yeah those are wonderful games when you
know all eight pawns are on the board
and the structure is flexible and you
don't really know i mean you have to
maneuver behind your pawns and you don't
really know how the structure is going
to look so exactly that could be as
flexible as possible
i i like this move f4 you do yes yes um
i want to follow it up with queen to f2
followed by g4 after that
getting frisky over there or f5 if you
don't
react to this move f4 well okay queen c7
queen c7 yeah if you want to play a five
player five it seems to
root to f1 rook to f1 it's more of a
birthday
sacrifice in exchange
this is one of those i believe your
exchange sacrifices good
uh kind of reactions
it would be pretty you know
so how do they increase the pressure
right you cannot go g4 immediately
because
that's when the queen c7
will uh prove to be useful i will take
on f4 and then go d5 so this is going to
be one okay okay i was gonna say rook f2
and rook f1 i think he wants to play d4
he wants to force black to uh exchange
that pawn on e5 for for either the
d-pawn or the f-pawn okay
is a3 a move for black
rook now doesn't think so very kgb
approach
by both players actually is
they're not revealing their cards this
move
i don't think it's really a threat
though because you are giving up the
square
h1 usually you try to just yes
get your king
off of the uh potential of a g1 check
that's one thing that doesn't magnus is
so good at
just improving his position
right and yeah i i was thinking that the
move b4 would give
magnus the square c4
instantly magnus responded with c3 c4
keeping the queen side closed
saying
i i forgo the c4 square
in order to put a knight on d5 but
here's the problem yeah knight to d4
but now yeah can we play f5
and i understand we have a bad bishop
and everything yes but we are more or
less guaranteed that the queen side is
going to be close that is true and you
know and we we will try to arrange this
g5 eventually it might have to be not
enough but at least white is kind of
guaranteed of any you know incidents
yeah f5 uh actually of the bishops yeah
like black nominally has a good bishop
but it's restricted with white pawns and
it doesn't have that many targets uh
queen to f2
f2
so well perhaps f5 is just you know to
have it as an idea not to rush with it
but
yep
is there some issues with f7 though he's
thinking
that there's a take and knight to d5
i'll move my queen in such a case anyway
so knight definitely
never but after bishop e6 that was
really attempting to resist he's asking
for okay it's just white has a free
attack at this point well uh
i would say maybe even it's time to get
on your running shoes and just get out
of the pawn store yeah but the problem
is like
whenever you are getting g5
and the knight will have to drop back
the knight d5 becomes a serious issue so
you'll have to spend quite quite a few
tempi
okay controls g5 and
moves the queen away from knight d5
exactly still it's not easy for white to
coordinate his whole
queen to g3 h4 g5 slow slow slow play so
now it's a big question do you play it
slow like rook i mean h4 bishop h3 and
maybe moving the king away you know
doubling the rooks or putting the rooks
on the second rate maybe you try to
go g5 right now and
you know create some mass
where you might have a better chance of
getting to the king but also
yeah the structure is not ideal and
maybe you are taking some risk right
right
uh one thing i'd also point out by the
way that the desirable queen g3 in many
of these cases
might just allow the knight to go to e2
to f4 rook d2
protecting against knight to e2 so
probably preparing the move queen to g3
and there you go he did stop knight e2
to f4 bishop c6 i think was useful just
to control d5 and that's going to h7 so
yeah so that when you do get kicked with
g5 the knight doesn't land
h4 no no he's not wrong something else
yeah what's interesting could this ever
be a scenario where you actually move
away the f3 knight
and you say okay you have a very
beautiful knight on d4 which does not
actually do anything
in terms of protecting
the king side right that's a good knight
g1 h4 knight h3 you know yeah
rook f
ii
knight h7 uh lanier very classical
player by the way
uh he's uh
he's putting up the old uh blockade and
by the way
g5 is very serious okay
that you have to amp assange because
then your rooks
take over
by the way uh
nepal born with black against shark
so exactly not planning to slow down
anytime soon but that's not slowing down
either this is no i think the move g
terrifying
asking too much of the position rook f8
is
as
um here and that realizes let me get
that knight to f6
and you play g5 after that yes and then
your bishop can cut
three yeah the bishop can come to h3 too
oh no don't take on g5 open the h file
uh oh
no no there's a sighting of
take with the h pawn queen to h4
for quincy five zero g5 is also kind of
a motif because knight h5 is an
immediate threat to mistakes was the
queen yes he senses a tactical
opportunity doesn't he 96.
defends the queen by the way knight of
six wait a second that could be just a
perpetual maybe he he's kind of
overlooked it he overlooked
oh
a lucky lucky save there it was a huge
uh huge advantage for magnus it sure
absolutely right
let's jump to the game of vessel and
topolof versus yvonne sarrich
wow
i'm looking at a a horde of black pawns
coming up the board wait a second
is character just winning i mean with
all those like the flanks of pawns
exactly i'm just thinking oh how am i
if i'm in vessel and shoes how am i
stopping these pawns
my goodness 10 seconds two six no no
nothing helps yeah nothing helps
c2 it's like space invaders they're just
oh
uh that was a
bad etiquette there
as
that's the clock
yeah queen c6 and vaseline resigns yeah
queen e5 check is only one check exactly
even surge considers his uh series of uh
wins and losses no draws and let's jump
is that draws uh wonderful rest a draw
against the wesley saw
yes did that game ever
how do you say develop into some kind of
battle when we left it it was just is
going to
uh be trades
by the way uh
uh christian that that the final
position of ivan sarich is
really a visual if there was a pawns on
g6 and h7 that would be like one of the
best pawn chains i've ever seen
g6h7 uh you don't know that's beautiful
that is
and by the way
by the way this bishop uh really is
crying too right i mean it's fenced in
by all of those pawns uh nice visual at
the end there
yeah absolutely absolutely and what
other games uh what happened in the
other games well let's see what happened
in uh ferugia versus mvl it seems like
mvl actually got this one um the last
time i checked it which was 30 seconds
ago it looked like a draw but let's see
what happened knight to f3 c4 it was
first actually that was piling up the
pressure early on let's take a look how
they opened up with this sort of
reversed sicilian position and after
that it felt like ferruccia in this end
game given the fact that he has the two
bishops and a lot of pressure on the
queen side as well not the stable
outposts for the knight on c6 it felt
like at this point he was slightly
especially at in this position after the
exchange of these two pawns not only
that right now i have a target to focus
on the pawn on b7 but i also potentially
could get my rook to the a file now i
have to get rid of the bishop first now
bishop to d4 and at this point bishop
takes c6 was just simply winning
missed by firuja rook to b8 king to d7
and the simple rook to b7 the king is in
shambles you cannot go forward and
activate the king because if you do go
king to e6 rook to e1 just picks up the
rook that's a problem and if you have to
stay on the eighth rank and uh stay
pinned on the eighth rank i can just
simply take the pawn i can give you a
check and then go rook to b1 create the
checkmating threat this is just simply
game over right now so big missed
opportunity for ferugia after bishop to
d4 he played the move rook to b1 and
that allowed black's position to
stabilize rook to c7 and we got to this
end game in which uh black just simply
picked up a piece that was a big blunder
bishop to f1 assuming that the only
response would be rook to d1 and then i
have time to go king to g2 but your rook
is on h7 maybe you shouldn't have taken
that pawn and play bishop f1 first
because right now after knight to g5
this uh rook is under attack you can
take my rook but i will pick up yours
and i will be a piece up still
white has a lot of pawns and this
position
after king to f6 rook to h6 this was the
moment once again after knight to f3
rook to d1 still within range of
equality knight rooked hd1 knight to g4
we got the piece back but now the king
is in some sort of danger you cannot
move the bishop because you're going to
get checkmated and i have a clear threat
as black i want to go rook to c7 rook to
h7 that's a check mate in the position
and this was the critical mistake why
king to h4 you have to wait for me play
any rook move probably rook to a1 or
rook to b1 not rook to d1 uh rook to e1
is also possible not rook to d1 because
that would allow knight to f2 and that's
a fork but if you go rook to e1 and then
rook to c7 and then you just move the
bishop away you give a check but my king
escapes so he played the move king to h4
huge mistake by ali reza and after rook
to c8 rook to h8 is just simply game
over and you cannot defend against it
you can try to fall back but that's just
simply checkmate in one move big game by
mvl and a big victory for the frenchman
guys in zagreb what do you have
thank you christian and we had a couple
of decisive victories with the black
pieces certainly janet pognan here so
i'm in the hallway and he said
man the handicap from the rapid is just
too big but at least today it's going
well nanastasi what happened in his game
it was interesting game with shakir
mamitjar of tyra's defense and later on
um they ended up and uh in the position
after g5 you can see that the king is a
little bit more open right now and
shakira of course
of course found this chance immediately
to sacrifice something he played queen
h5 here and after
um nepo took the challenge and took the
knight he could actually repeat the
moves but shakira will never repeat the
moves if he has even one chance to play
on and he decided that yes of course why
not to try king is open
so he actually continued his attack he
grabbed all those pawns for the bishop
and ended up in the position with like
three pounds for the bishop but still
the attack is you know it's going on
it's happening still it's not that easy
for um yani punisher to defend even
though computer doesn't like position of
light uh don't be tricked it's still not
over and after a few moves they ended up
in this position like this move did take
c5 opening the center for example so
black had to be really precise quincy
five rogue d1 king c7 now bishop c6
follows of course you cannot take with
queen roxy one so that's why um look i
mean white pieces are really active and
we have three pawns for the bishop um
but look what happened after i mean then
the game suddenly changed yes it hits
its track maybe it was not a bad idea
for shakhriar to exchange maybe queens
here i don't know it's hard to say but
he continued let's say
he was still hoping to get something
probably um and
later on after all this you know mess
after few exchanges
jan found his game finally yes i mean
after
he managed to actually to open uh to to
change the rooks and then queen and
bishop became very dangerous couple
against the king so after that i mean
actually it was time for shakhriar to
admit that yeah okay i it didn't work
out i mean i had to make a draw but it
didn't really happen
and um he didn't find a way to defend
this position and after a couple of
moves had to admit that it's just a
checkmate this coming yeah so he
resigned here what a drama yes i mean
but shakira really tried his best didn't
work this time very dramatic but nepo is
the one that takes advantage of it
unfortunately as he mentioned the rapid
didn't go very well not a lot of points
for him another game in which well the
players don't have a lot of points but
they are in the tournament topalov did
play against ivan saric and you can see
the world champion the former world
champion very frustrated with himself he
came up out of sight the playing call in
spanish was just saying how much better
he was in this position and that he
couldn't believe that he just threw it
away and that's exactly what happened
let's to go to some of the critical
moments because the game was pretty
messy if you look at it it's this type
of king's indian setup with the pawns on
e5 and f5 c5 included and it's super
super messy we know that the king's
indian goes to very fun positions and
look what happened it seems like topalov
was in control of the position he had an
excellent chance once he got his knight
to e6 it's a very powerful knight it
does cost a pawn on b5 but you get this
huge attack and he was cruising look at
this queen coming to h5 and i was trying
to cash in knight d8 attacked the rook
the rook has to move it doesn't have an
option you can't allow queen e8 chuck so
the rook must go to f8 but you can now
catch it with bishop e7 the rook
actually runs out of moves you cannot
really play the move knight f6 uh
because after queen g6 the crook is
still trapped nothing has changed and
you're getting mated and the knights
attacked so this didn't really work out
but instead after the move queen d3 he
didn't find the move uh queen v8 instead
he played the move knight queen g6 and
this was just a mistake unfortunately
for topalov because he is giving up the
anchor pawn for the knight that is
posted on e6 and once queen takes d5
came on the board he had to get rid of
his knight play knight takes g7 this is
a king's indian bishop it's not exactly
the bishop that you want to take with
that powerful knight and after rook
takes g7 it's obvious that black has
more or less consolidated and that the
pawns eventually will roll how far did
they roll check out the final position
because
as the spectators were saying at some
point they looked at the screen and they
said well
yvonne has a lot of pawns and a lot of
pawns they are this was the final
position of the game i actually even
thought that it was a rook on f1
originally and thought okay this is
complicated then realized the bishop
absolutely hopeless vaseline resigned in
this position and for the locals he uh
great style believed that ivan won a
game finally you know after so many
losses we are so happy for ivan of
course not good news for vaseline
topalov but the tournament continues the
tournament continues and we still have
big fights in the next round maxine
vasher lagra who has been surging
through today is going to be playing
against magnus carlsen so that's going
to be a fantastic match to follow we're
going to take a short commercial break
and be right back with that game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
after 13 rounds of blitz here are our
standings
yeah well as you could as you can see
still two points lead with five rounds
to go i'm afraid the answer to the
question who's going to stop mike
wisconsin is nobody well and look check
it out magnus and yeah they got nine and
a half each out of the 13. so they're
the top blitzers but mvl is going to be
playing magnus in our very next round
this is it let's take a look at the
pairing so this is it yeah and we are
wisconsin with the white pieces
and
also quite an interesting ride that will
be keeping an eye on saric against
mamidyarov wesley saw will get the
chance to score against vessel interpol
with the white pieces and then dominguez
will play one for rest very nice as we
get ready for this round 14
again 18 rounds of blitz so still some
time but that two-point gap christian
that
wow that's so big that has to be cut to
one point soon to make it interesting it
has to be done soon yes uh and mvl with
the white pieces we have to remember
enviol is a very strong blitz player
when he's in shape he can see tactics so
fast so this is definitely going to be a
good chance but nine and a half points
each for nepo and magnus that really
tells me that those two guys are really
informed and the fact that mbl has eight
also pretty good nine and a half points
is how many an apple scored in the blitz
section so far
nine and a half out of 13. so today he's
three out of four that's quite
impressive actually
indeed the only game he lost was against
mvo with the white pieces well you
called it at the very top of the show as
you showcased both magnus and john i
don't know
jan looks almost like uh bored there
like
okay yeah okay
yeah who's next
and
rory lopez there they're the berlin
defense and not a really aftermath no
rookie one oh oh
i think rookie one is better than d4
though he used to be one of the few
players who actually played the end game
exactly it's so interesting how our
perception changed yes right i mean at
first when kramnik is to play we were
bored with the nan game right right it
turns out the anti-berlin's are even
more boring
rooting for the end game to happen not
the anti-berlin this anti-berlin right
yeah because if you play d3 d3 it can be
anything i agree right this rookie one
98 immediately without bishop f6
and actually i think mvl was one of the
few players that did beat magnus carlsen
in the uh berlin end game
a few years back in the classical
oh this b3 three line e3 okay
okay uh what do we know about the b3
line question what does theory
teach us not that much uh there's only
three games that have been played but
one of them is
mvl versus wesley saw mvl against wesley
and how did the c6 was played in that
one wesley handle c6 and bishop to e6
are the two main moves right
bishop e6
bishop e6 i kind of appreciate a little
bit more because it kind of cuts but no
um
magnus lights
c7 c6 yeah queen f3 that's what their
idea yeah queen f3 if you capture d4
it's okay d1 or something they're still
following that game
the game between uh mvl and west how how
did the bishop e6 was the movie that one
probably avoiding any sort of knight
takes d5 ideas bishop e6 you said bishop
e6 at this point right at this point
isn't well yes because you have to stop
queen f4 right
and bishop e6 means that you're
available for bishop
without allowing rook takes e7 now
there's an interesting move at this
point you can play the move knight to f5
and just sacrifice the exchange and say
that after bishop takes f8 i do pick up
the d4 pawn right takes d4 with the
temple then i pick up
the bishop on f8 and then i have a lot
of pressure on the dark squares
that's actually interesting that's
actually i find very attractive for
black and that opens up the game that
turns the tables as to who's fighting
for the initiative yeah and if you don't
take on a fade
then black solves all the problems at
once right now i'm not even sure you're
losing a pawn right because knight f5 is
actually threatening the pawn twice yes
it's like yes you can play knight
but yeah but then at the very least
rookie
has no problem whatsoever so night after
night
that's very enterprising will mag go for
it but magnus is falling by quite a lot
on time i think he chose bishop
yes
he spent some time on that decision
though
he's uh under three minutes with mvl
over five minutes
well uh for me that fi i find him with
queen f4 very attractive you have to
drop back
then i have bishop to d3 there is queen
a5 that might be a counter tickle
they're still following the game no nvl
versus west yell against wesley and
bishop to day three was played in that
game as well
well perhaps magnus's decision you know
it's kind of influenced by the
tournament uh situation right like if he
would be on the back foot and was trying
to catch up with someone then yeah night
five makes perfect sense take risks
right but now you just have to maintain
your two points leads and his decision
against dominguez was based on that fact
as well he didn't play that end game
which probably was better for white
he just offered the draw and moved on
all right queen f6 now
white has to trade question mark no okay
trading in this way
once again any deviation from the game
between mvl and wesley so well perhaps
there is yeah now it's no longer showing
yes h4 was uh the new move uh-huh and we
are coming with a spicy improvement
yeah
spicy novelty that was a joke you're
supposed to
oh
really
very nice very nice
guess who just woke up
okay take the queen bishop d7 what's the
problem i mean that's
pretty easy
okay that
kind of gives the knight a square so
that we could trade and put the knight
on g7
it's a bit of a psychological discussion
i'm i'm guessing right i don't really
want to take on f4 on your terms right
yeah i'll make you take one of 6. the
knight on e2 blocking the rook means
that whenever i play queen takes f4 it's
a kind of a relief
of sorts
so finally uh mvl broke the
quite still tiny bit gorilla right gordy
well
really
yeah i mean f3 g4 yeah i understand the
position is equal but this is kind of
the better side of equality
magnus actually went 98 back after
bishop d7 g4 he went back to e8
so he wants the knight on d6 perhaps
on our e6 like he gets knight c7
wants to put the knight on e6
but that's yeah c does look like one of
those weinstein endings right and then
who knows maybe
okay so do you avoid all together the
exchange of the rooks or do you exchange
one pair of groups that that's the
question i think you want to keep all
together h1 rook to h1 okay
um okay since you're telegraphing
h5
either i'm playing f6 with the idea of
keeping it closed or h6 with the idea of
keeping it closed knight e6 knight e6
king g3 okay probably swapping the
knights and then
and then what yeah that's a big question
f6 the thing is with the king on f4 i
have h5 as one and you don't have the
move g5 so yeah but that's careful black
obviously is going to oh king g7 h5
e he okay he captures they're allowing
h6 by the way
or just king f4
isn't backwards in a bit of a trouble no
he doesn't think so h6
h65 can i play g5 myself right now well
for
yes but then
you take it like that
f6
with a check g5 with a check and ends up
playing king h6 yes
that's the point that might be a problem
it's interesting when magnus plays even
though symmetrical position there is
still some content in there yes
right so the tension is still around
at hcfg
and now
okay g5 check g5 just yeah just chase
the king away trade go rookie 8 degree a
draw
yeah this is really
yeah okay this was so tame uh i can't
tell you
uh i'm gonna let you surprise to the
game of ferugia if you don't mind jan
nepo nepo against
nepo seemingly got himself into trouble
did he yeah
i think he's bishop on eight is an
exchange down yeah but wait a second
specifically yeah specifically
his uh resign time he could have been
relying on like black not being able to
take on f5 right now because he's like
the last move what's green f5 and then
yeah rook g4 rook takes e8 for instance
yeah that bishop e5 that should be fine
that's a desperado if i've ever seen one
but
it might be better you know but also the
f2 part is sagging so by the way in
passing
uh and i think magnus did make a draw
and look at
nepo is just disgusted he's just shaking
his head what have i done i mean jeez
uh
let's jump to wesley yeah maybe wesley
gets a chance
has the window been open to crack for
wesley
now that nepo has lost again oops where
are you
kind of that's quite there it is
position right hold on white's king is
exposed
but look at the queen for black right
it's a nice clean it's not doing
anything oh we kind of lost our
is it blackout
oh no whoa we have a blackout
uh seriously
we have a black house
yes as we see there that the staging
lights
something
is
and they're back
it looks like they're like the disco
lights
but one thing about uh
extremely warm in croatia so this could
be leading to the blackouts ah
it's close to 40 degrees celsius
okay bishop to g4 so he returns well he
wants to he wants to be six and get rid
of this knight maybe all right well it
was the problem with the rook f1 he was
like one step seven as well yeah yeah
trying this side essentially you you
wouldn't mind exchanging the knight on
d5 right just thinking that this uh
queen is a little trap so something like
rook c1 and rook takes b7 yeah
or well i should
i should take capturing on b7 as
immediately doesn't he win an exchange
by the way like rook takes b7 queen a8
runs into knight c7 queen c8 that could
run into the 90s e7 but maybe then you
take and i don't know invade with the
queen to c2
the game is not over but yeah white is
taking
gift foreign upon as a starter
and then you start to think what's
interesting
rook c1 you'd be you'd be surprised yeah
rook c1 is good
first choice of an engine at least the
weak engine that i have was it was
remarkable queen takes b7 just straight
the queens the knight is as good as
powerful as the rook yeah that was wow
and around plus two for white wow
uh
the the thing that put me off was the
fact that this move rook to d7
uh does stop uh those ideas of rook b7
as well as knight e7 that was why i was
thinking rook b7
right away but queen b7 queen p7 was
that
amazing uh white seemingly has
first of all the body count d5 is e5 an
option
queen c3 what's this so this one has an
extra pawn wait a second queen c3 if
there is no threat there then yeah yeah
d8
b7 which can't be taken
did he just blunt it terribly yeah rook
d8
rook ca that's great
by the way after queen c3 it seems that
white has lost the thread and that the
move like h5 you know just to avoid the
back rank issues would have been would
have been better for black and shark
just finished won a game against ivan
saric so ivan sarish continues to be
kind of a punching bag i'm sorry
let's jump to lanier
van forest and a handshake
and jordan has won his black pieces
that's a big victory for young jordan
queen g3 check is a visual
look at this uh final position oh yeah
with four knights queen g3 you take f4
you give a check on g3 and then you take
on f4 i'm guessing right f3 is hanging
probably you take one f4 and just just
like mate
extra material for black as well never
mind the two pawns but for jordy that's
a big win
as uh he was hanging around in our
standings jordy is is that how you call
them in yeah in the netherlands
yeah they call it we got jordy we we got
danya dania yeah
and by the way uh if we haven't
announced it don't recall the fact no no
no we didn't said we do we are going to
have a very special guest
one mr gary kasparov is going to be
joining us in zagreb
maybe in moments uh we'll see as we jump
to zagreb or not what happened did five
decisive games in this round absolutely
well wow
while we wait for uh gary uh to come
maybe
except for carson making a draw
excuse me yeah no i mean that was one
ring yeah and here it is okay so wesley
is one or rather half a point half step
closer right yeah but there won't be
enough rounds right it won't be if it
will be he's that slow pace would be
enough round so he really starts to but
nepo's loss was huge that really really
how he's joined by mvl and van forest so
tie for the third mm-hmm
and ali raza in sixth position closely
behind
what is it it's a very short field right
now tight for the third uh
very very very nice yeah yeah well if
you'd be
uh let's say before the tournament i
would tell you okay the the you know the
standing is gonna split and there will
be the leading group and kind of guys
lagging behind europe of course it's
like by default you'd go with one for us
being yeah it looks like uh nepo
magnus carlson versus nepal that's gotta
be our marquee that's so much for sure
for round 15. also
doesn't have zero points mvl that will
be a great second uh game that will
uh be our
our second choice yep
but
magnus vs nepo who will be the best
blitzer
i think there's a point and a half now
between
magnus and nepo and the blitz in the
blitz right and magnus has ten
um eight and a half yes yeah
has lost the last one ah gotcha
that was a terrible result for nappa
with white i mean that final
position
what to do i don't know what he did uh
in fact christian what did
nepo do to to to have such an awful
position when we when we clued in on it
absolutely we do have some time before
gary joins us so
maybe
we can uh see what happened in this one
it did seem like nepal was getting a
little bit of an advantage out of the
opening but take a look at this point
after queen to c8 a bishop to h2 came on
the board and immediately firuja took
the bull by the horns and
took away the knight from the
centralized square d4 with the move c5
not only that but i'm also going to
follow it up with c4 and block the light
square bishop beautiful move by ali reza
and this allowed him to take over at
this game but we do have alejandro in
zagreb with one gary kasparov alejandro
take it away
thank you christian we're here with the
13th world chess champion gary casper
welcome to the show enjoying the grand
chester so far absolutely absolutely and
i enjoyed it more than last year because
i'm watching not black
it's definitely a different feeling yeah
absolutely
uh
tell us a little bit about your events
here in croatia we don't we have not
only the grand chess tour but it's a
whole festival of chess around us
yeah absolutely it's this that was a
whole idea to actually to use branches
to prevent uh um as a booster for chess
in croatia in the whole region so i had
one of my kasparoa foundation branches
here kcf adriatic and uh you know it's
this tournament is an ideal opportunity
to
bring uh croatian kids kids from
neighboring countries they play uh
but on top of that we also have a
special session with
european stars and this year of course
all ukrainians so that was also quite an
experience um
uh the two of them were really good uh
especially these the i was very
impressed by a ten-year-old kid
yeah it's uh somehow you know the the
universe works in a very strange fashion
he's from butcher so we all know the the
name of the city for tragedy and for
atrocities and crimes committed by
russian troops but we may may
know the city as a place of one of the
greatest talents again a bit too early
to say but uh you know at age ten to
show such a mature such a mature
understanding of the game and so i i was
impressed and also igor simonenko who's
i am at age 13 and so yeah ukraine
definitely has talent so that's that's
it's not just you know the war where but
it's it's the the country is still very
generous with with talents i'm sure not
only in chess but i think that you know
we will
we will hear more about
ukrainian ukrainian teams winning events
in the future 10 and 13 it's just like
they get younger and younger these
talents are amazing yeah look now they
have access to
to data to information that you know i
remember myself you know that age you
know trying just to collect you know
just the pieces of information from
newspapers from chess magazines you know
making you know the clips and uh and and
writing something from the books and now
they just have to push a button or just
you know swipe their finger on the
screen and
um so they
they learn fast um and of course they
can play a lot of tournaments so we
didn't have the same luxury and so at
the age 12 13 they were already
experienced international players so
this is now
uh we grandmaster at age 12 uh at mishra
for instance yeah that's no one is
surprised about it anymore so it's the
um and um again i i'm very pleased that
you know in croatia so this is my
adopted country so the chess is now is
gaining popularity and
there's a big support from the
government
and and of course you know super bad
super united croatia's their their
company uh um it's it's they're already
you know making commitments for for at
least for the next year so it seems that
you know with super but uh sponsorship
chess
game new grounds in eastern europe
bucharest warsaw
zagreb so i think it's it's great
because uh we we have many talents in
this part of the world but not many
tournaments so actually when i was
active chess player i uh except because
live i never played in eastern europe
because it was soviet block and they
were secondary tournaments right yeah um
and now uh you know we see you know
quite uh quite a boost and um i'm i've
no doubt that you know all these events
you know in
that
like one in zagreb or in bucharest they
will help to
not not just generate interest but also
will bring new talents young talents
from respect respective countries it's
been an explosion of talent from here
from neighboring countries so we see it
everywhere everybody trying to be the
next magnus talk about a little bit
about the tournament especially because
magnus now is on the way to retirement
that's a mistake
but i think the tournament is
representative of the chess world
everybody's fighting for second place
and magnus head and shoulders still
ahead of everybody look it's interesting
because it's you know we
i i mean i know i i yeah i was you know
it's uh i was an issue so that's this
because everybody want you to lose
everybody wanted you know just youtube
to falter and
and i think it's somehow just i think in
the in the beginning of the tournament
magnus was
yeah he was it was you could feel he
could feel that he was uneasy yeah i
think it's a big statement that he has
been preparing and uh and
uh he was probably not sure what's next
and uh and it showed that as his game
was
not very convincing so not at all and
then it is it's at one point that we
said oh maybe he's now going down boom
the train magnus was
back on the rails back on track
yesterday was an incredible amount of
victory seven wins two losses no draws
at all and today everybody says about
the mother style it's all the styles
aggressive styles
and it's also you know it's energy so
it's the
yo you watch his games and as if his
pieces had more energy so it's the
i think he's not
taking on you know uh secondary position
so that's all all the best players in
the world are here so but they were no
match and we'll see what happens now so
it's the uh it's abs
relatively slow start for him
relatively slow start he's still way
ahead one and a half points that's how
he started today yeah but it's it's it's
it's also it's the it's
he's very um he's very um stable so it's
it's he's you know we look at his
performance so that's just even if he's
not doing great so he's still on top
while uh the the players you know it's
uh some of them had a great day
yesterday but you know but not doing
well today mvl yesterday was not you
know look very bleak today he just you
know he's doing great but you know it's
again as you said you know
this the second third you know positions
could change magnus still you know
stands on top the world champion is not
going to be defending his title and the
is the same in the women's section who
you find is not participating in the
world championship cycle at all are the
matches just not as important for these
top of the top players or what's going
on okay um
we can have a long philosophical
discussion what is the world title
it's the
legally yeah you can say legally today
you can make a case that fiji owns the
world championship match though you can
still you know
have tons of arguments about it because
and that's what the arguments i had was
feeding in the 90s right when i walked
away though i just you know defended
magic against the challenger nigel short
just outside defeated because uh feeding
never called but winning the first world
champion but when he was the six right
so which means we inherited a tradition
that existed before feed it so from 1886
to 1948 so there were five world
champions and and finney basically
included them incorporated them so we
know about 16 world champions so we we
cherish our history
going back to steinitz right some could
say even probably you know you can go be
uh
uh uh
beyond so this is or just back on in
timeline and talking about morphy but
but let's start with official
quote-unquote official championship so
1896 by the way saint louis
play play the role in this event that's
how they started yes
and um and this you know this kind of
collision has never been resolved
technically you can say that in in 2002
when we signed this agreement in prague
because it was myself and kramnik so
yeah we
somehow um abandoned our rights you know
as world champions so we merged you know
feed in line with the with the uh
historical line um and and then when
kramnik played topple off so that says
everything has been you know um
um
amalgamated
but still you know the question is
magnus is the best player today and and
for the public he is the
cold world champion
whatever title you want to attu to add
to his name he's still the best and i
it would be very odd to see any match
called world championship without magnus
i don't know there's an answer for this
collusion but because at the end of the
day
i don't know let's fantasize what if
what if magnus plays yacht outs i mean
just you know or whoever so how are you
going to handle it so this is
who will consider
match let's again say
uh nepo playing ding
where i don't know where you're going to
play so this is the so play what it will
be considered a v match or a match
or you know it will just uh you know
bring us back to the situation in late
90s and it's just yeah with all due
respect to let's say to california and
and and customize
yeah i'm sorry that's that's not not
exactly you know the the
the world champions that's that are
remembered because you also had by the
way also fifa had uh its own world
championships back in 19 i think it was
almost back in 1924 i think the madison
one was the first one to feed the
congress then they even had the boogaloo
buff
and that's that's that's that's that's
how they actually use bugalupu as a
challenger to lurkin so maybe someone
someone else i mean this is fide had its
own you know champions yes with the
amateurs champions and
and uh and the uh like the big league
always opposed back back back then in
before world war ii uh any of the
attempts to intervene so it's back in
1937 1938 so it was all you know like a
club so yeah again i don't have answers
for that um so i think that's going back
to what you said uh it's maybe this the
old format
just
is easy role maybe we should look for
something like rancher's tour mike made
this statement i i didn't pay much
attention what he said at the opening
ceremony that he strongly preferred
branches to format with classic rapid
and blitz to the traditional uh
cycle
maybe that's an answer again
we don't want play you know just for for
fun we play for public
and if there is a public demand to to to
make these changes
maybe we should consider it and we asked
a lot of the players on their interviews
what would you do to change the world
championship format a ton of them said
the current format is archaic they would
prefer shorter time controls well i
think that we should look something like
the rancher's tool
it's this is it make it more dynamic and
i think it's very natural to incorporate
you know the rabbit and blitz into the
system so that's again that's what
people want to see that's why we have
millions and millions of new followers
they just
they
like it or not
nobody wants to
wait eight hours for the result of the
game yeah now maybe you can play some of
them but you also need you know like you
know you have oprah music but you also
have other forms of music so you cannot
have just just you know long wagoner
opera
it's just as the only dish in the menu
final question
dingle red play against yani palmiachi
do you think that the winner of this
match a match runs the risk of being
placed the same as halifan or kasim
janov as a world champion with the big
asterisk look is the
it's more likely you know
yeah you can go back to car prof team
and match because yeah
california casino they were not even top
ten when they won the try or their
feeder titles uh here you're talking
about
okay you may start arguing three four
two top five players so that's the yeah
and that's that's the difference but um
i don't know what kind of title they can
carry so i mean i i definitely will not
will never uh consider the winner of
this match if this match takes place as
a seventh world champion so just for me
the only way for the 17th world champion
to to to appear someone to be added to
the list that started with steinitz it's
to beat michael scrolls
or if he walks away then it's another
story but as long as magnus is playing
is this is it's you can't you know you
can't consider you know uh any match a
real world championship match by the way
going all the way back so that's what we
know from history that would still need
a little bit of mystery because a long
time ago
uh the reason why the official match
first official match was was declared in
1886 though the shinings played i
understand there were still events
because nobody was was ready to accept a
title as long as morphe was alive morphy
died in 1883 and only after morphy's
death they were ready to to play the
match that
chess public accepted as as as a world
championship match there you go the 13th
world champion says if someone doesn't
beat magnus over the board in a match
that's not going to be the 17th i'm sure
everybody's going to have their own
opinions for that gary thank you for
joining us here in the show we're
minutes away actually i'm one minute
away from starting the next round
absolutely you want to stay with us
just just have a look let's see what are
the pairings that we have uh here
we got evie eleven four as well i gotta
see the magnus knapple magnus snapper
what a nice coincidence
actually it was a case
yeah we are just about a moment away
from start we can just as uh magnus
plays white and magnus plays white yeah
we you want to analyze this one yeah
let's have a look of course that's the
it's the it's uh emily had a good chance
against magnus you know i was surprised
he didn't push pawn on h6 right it was
it was it looked scary for the world
champion there yeah but it was it was
yeah he was under pressure and then it
was at one point he could have played h6
check
instead india's intermediate check and
then take the knight you can even look
at that yes this is yeah that's i and it
will be
yeah this is the
yeah here is a moment yes no here yet
here here is the moment play h6 right of
course
check and it looks and then take the
knight and then take the knight with all
these dark square weaknesses yeah
because king f6 g5 doesn't work this is
the pawn only says two weeks so you
should go there then you take and you
should play f6 but then you start
pushing pawns here because g5 you always
have this this is the weakness there so
there's a chance it's i'm not saying
it's it's it's it's it's nearly winning
but but there's a very very good chance
and he could have okay and the game is
on its way magnus using this kind of
his favorite line his queen takes d4
maxim actually had a great prep against
him in the rapid i don't know yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was it was a perpetual yes
yeah but but
it's um
well we'll see so g3 this is the
famously play bishop h65 this is some
sort of a very interesting line yeah f5
f5 the computer just
fast move
[Laughter]
this is why the 10 year olds are good at
chestnut
computers have changed the game so much
f5 is currently considered to be the
best move hand but it's getting worse
and worse for black yeah i think after
bishop b2 in this position the move is
bishop h6 exactly that's that's what i
say and then f6 and this is dynamism yes
yeah the dynamic you go boom boom boom
but in this position with bishop g7 i
thought this was actually considered to
be bad for black of course it's blood
it's bad it looks bad
number five
world champion now in this belief that
this is even playable for the black side
so this
looks horrible for black
so explain it to our audience a little
bit what is it that
you think is what's going to be causing
black trouble here
yeah i don't like dig
i can't even explain it also it's maybe
it's not that bad but i just i don't
like
uh this is the com somehow it's
combination of moves f5 queen five
bishops there's no plans five visual six
knight f6 i understand because this is
you try to be dynamic so just it's the
you you you create weakness in your
position but you you know you try to
compensate it by the activities right as
of now
i could see we
have weaknesses but yeah but in 95
killing that activity trying to get some
uh just taking away the pieces from the
board leaving those weaknesses behind
yeah that's just this end game
take take will be eight now
everybody has another move to make
f7 on the board
it just feels terrible right knight f3
coming knight g5 on tap i'm just
starting
bishop c4 maybe
h390 bishop c495 maybe yeah
well you cannot eat xf5 magnus doesn't
it doesn't bother
he just wants to create you know
weaknesses bishop five he may probably
plays f4 and then it's united three so
magnus
that's just a typical yeah you'll just
you know have some slight advantage so
this is the in black black position the
center slightly compromised okay okay
not compromised but this is
yeah it's it's maybe not much but it's
just it magnus i think we'll enjoy it
though it's
two point island against three i mean
everything that black has done not
compensated
now
a four knight of three
let's find out the world champion in
thought so far a little bit of a slogan
for a blitz bishop c4 right
he wants to force 95
and then go back just back back and then
f4
and that's what's going on 96 on the
board
yeah no he should probably now take and
then then f4
yes 10 it's maybe it's not that's you
know clear this f4 maybe g4 anyone not g
for
years maybe it's not
knight d5 maybe was not the greatest
idea well knight d5 still returns that
advantage nice f6 played and well the
computer's loving your idea knight takes
f6 king takes f6 follow it up with f4
but that's that's that's that's the most
natural and then bishop maybe go on a
three and then yes g4 and then knight d2
so it's the end again this is this pawns
are it's the squeeze right it's a yeah
that's the
the the
i mean if you have you know
queens and somebody's with attacks it's
fine but it's it's the static static
problems static problems that's the
problems yeah so
knight c6
yeah i think bishop for three minutes
will play the bishop's knight d7 yes i
love them bishop f3 it's so natural to
play knight f3 but not as accurate i'm
not sure maybe now maybe now
so uh
who wants to put i don't know it's the
yeah bishop of three years exactly 92
yes
well world champions right guys
still yeah bishop bishop before rook f1
this looks really bad actually it's not
bad but it's just you know it's the
black has no no contemplate and and for
magnus is just you know it's a
it's the favorite type of
absolutely so that's like
and yeah time-wise so this is almost
about even 244 for mario and three
minutes from now it's amazing nipple
prepared to be definitely this is there
was the they must have a world
championship match and this is i mean
playing f5 and then bishop g7 what's the
point
although when napo came in he said he
was in no mood to repeat the lines from
the world championship and he was
preparing the backdrop there
yeah i know but it's just still
oh magnus found a better move knight c5
knights history oof
this king on f7 the activity difference
of the pieces
yeah
you can almost make the moves
automatically right rookie one coming
well
doesn't feel like black is creating a
threat but holding on for now how do you
break through in this position
i think we should probably see four now
i would say polopolis because e65 i just
want to avoid this i'll play probably
probably
but c4 maybe e e now e5 is a little bit
e5
perhaps that's why magnus is considering
his move here but c4 play
is exactly like each other because he's
e6 you don't want e65 so this is that's
the you want to
yeah
and knight is
[Music]
immediately targeting that movement
exactly yes
i would have
tried d5 maybe i would have tried if i
was still bad still pretty nasty because
it's just the black has no contemplation
you can see with the last moves h6 a6
not really creating very much yet
b5 does seem like an idea time to go a4
d497
b497 is still yeah it's still still
surviving still surviving is
barely survived maybe g4
g4 g4 g4 f5 g4
i love g4 just making that king weak or
rook h3 played immediately no not
immediately whether you play rook h3o i
would start with g4 one on g4
oh getting some time maybe rookie three
pack
and i love the move g4 it's just one
start attack you know okay it plays b5
you can take on b5 and then f5
no worried about the counter play there
right yeah but beef people know also
weak souls yeah what cut counter play
someone is there and then you see if he
takes them this is the
there you go
activate your rooks
yeah yes i think it's i think black
teams can do something right e693 uses
and otherwise a five
that's not so yeah it's so complicated
to create anything knight d7
97 well entirely
yeah that's the he's he's trying to oh
that's five anyway the way yeah so it's
there
doesn't care that knight comes to e5
yeah but it's the
id5 was the
the only move he is now because taking
tekken seems to expose the king 95
played yeah without the five i would
have probably wait
i'll probably do yes you know
right because the move 97 was geared
against that exactly yeah so this is
maybe
it's the i would have
not rushed you know with with f5
a4
a4 takes takes
feels like with the knight on e5 but
it's the it's five was was
definitely premature i was like maybe h4
just move you know continue this advance
there or maybe a4 if you want to play
four and a five so but
why knight on d7 i don't know what's
what was black's next move right this
year
what's what would be his machine's best
suggestion here
uh it says knight d7 it likes to move
knight c3 as the best move or h3 just
keeping the position okay so this is
this f5 was improvement still you know
it's interesting so because his own
attack but but he has some counter play
well players are down to about just over
a minute each
remember they do have those two seconds
still
unpleasant
yeah
spot on h6 is just about to drop yeah
because this is the second rook also
will come yes yeah so rook rook g2 check
this is rook h8 rook h3 is all right it
sounds like a pontification
and i think that's why nap was taking so
long in this move he doesn't see a good
way to defend the pawn
where's the counter play
b5 there we go
what is the point of this if i take
this is the only chance for this he
wants to
he wants to die you know
uh
but look if i simply take two times
what's happening to king israel i
think the king is safe on b4 right okay
absolutely for before absolutely before
see no
yeah there you go a takes b5 as well i
see no oh rook c5 hitting the knight and
the pawn
knight c3 rook g2 i guess you have
rookie
you're rookie to take the king a3 or
while king is free
so just this is now
i could see i could see a passport
yeah what i see here that's
yeah but the b5
i'm
what was the best proof instead of b5
here rookie two and a quarter
yeah but that's the yeah that's the
and then tries to call the ending yes
exactly yes but that's very true you
know ideas a59 very interesting idea
actually this is a5 knight c6 basically
they're keeping you know king on a3 okay
but now it's that's
a rook c8 and that's gonna be a second
point
yeah but let's do it
rook takes h6 on the board nepal down to
20 seconds as well not a lot of time for
him but it's not about 20 seconds it's
about it's about that position that's
also true check blocks of the knight
that's it that's it right that's it
magnus just that's it that's it
rg4 takes a four last last
last 10 rooks three rooks is freedom
rook c3 just solid move there you go
world champion
v6 on the board rp5
still is there a matter of technique at
this point yeah f6
rook c7
rook b4
okay last chance
says nope
you have six works c3
and
meanwhile wesley is so i'm being told
has won his game against steven
sideridge double of b dominguez we'll
take a look at those games after this
one
and
well it's becoming a little complicated
not a lot of progress so far for magnus
yeah seems a bit stupid f6 at one point
he could have played right as i
suggested
we'll go back to that position rook on
f1
is it getting dicey
nice three no that's three
ah knight c3 was great
this fork on d5 this king on f6 just
such in a bad position
oh it's a queen it's a queen that is a
queen
queen is coming rook c6 played with one
second on the clock
there we go
and he's resigned i think yeah well this
is the earthquake king gives a move like
king f7 here
that's interesting
stole you know
magnus
unstoppable
this was a big chance for netflow with
the black pieces but uh there was no
chance there was no chance i mean this
is
the moment they reach this end game so i
think it's very clear that's this so
what's happened today in the round so
it's the
who is who is behind magnus now nobody
is ah there's nobody that's basically
that's basically the answer magnus is in
first place and there's a bunch of
people somewhere somewhere else i think
we have dinner on time
[Laughter]
well gary thank you so much for joining
us here in the studio thank you we're
going to go to our studio in st louis to
call the last games remaining and uh
well this tournament is all about over
guys okay
thank you gary gary proving that he
still knows how to move the pieces miro
as he was predicting many of magnus's
moves and
magnus's moves were really good
he's so enthusiastic as well yeah right
he beat uh nepo pretty convincingly i
would say and then uh
mvl has just beaten jordan vin forrest
uh as well so
the tournament is all but over magnus is
cruising to victory
but mvl clear third by virtue of his
victory over jordan so yasser asked and
you shall receive five decisive games
finally
yeah you were complaining about those
draws and thought
we were getting so many decisive games
but here's our standings after 15 rounds
reminding everybody there are 18 rounds
of blitz
and magnus carson no surprises at first
position wesley so he's not slowing down
still one and a half points behind mvl
clear third but with no realistic
chances of catching up with magnus
exactly yeah there you can see that the
magnus is as far as blitz is concerned
magnus is dominant 11 out of the 15 but
wesley mvl and yan all have nine and a
half
uh
proving their medal uh that there are
great blitzers
alireza
hell okay
catches up a little bit and here's our
pairings for round 16 uh yeah so that's
mbl against the paulov nepal with one
forest mamadiarov carlson saric olivreza
and then dominguez was a song
tell us what our marquee matchup should
be uh well
what would you have to stay with the
world champion right still stay with the
world
carlson yes
and sure there are some really good
players in the field okay shaq we
haven't
highlighted much of his games he hasn't
performed that well let's see if he can
uh
upset uh the runaway horse and christian
over to you not only that but the only
way this uh the standings in this
tournament uh change is if magnus loses
a game so that's why i think we need to
stick with magnus's games but i was
having a look at this game between van
forest and mvl because this was crucial
for the standings and to be honest mvl
was completely busted out of the opening
completely possible as you shall see in
just a few seconds and this was
the position after the opening e5 knight
to e4 very nice preparation by van
forest i have to say he was blitzing out
his moves up to this point and this has
already given him a big advantage now
the problem in black's position is that
at some point you will want to castle
and i already have a lot of my forces
concentrated against your castle
especially after this move knight to g5
f fg5 very dominant move and after
bishop to e7 queen to h5 was played in
the game and it makes a lot of sense you
want to get to g7 giving a white a
decisive advantage nevertheless as we
will see later on this was not the most
precise move queen to f3 was just
killing black at at this point you
cannot castle because knight ace h7 is
always going to be a big problem given
the fact that the bishop is already set
up on this diagonal you cannot take back
knight to f6 would just simply be
checkmate in two moves so you cannot
play that move
how do you defend the pawn on f7 well
you can go rook to f8 but that just
gives up a pawn and check this out for
example if you try to continue root to
f8 boom i have this idea as well take
queen to h5 rook uh to f7 now that i
cleared the h file i have a forced
checkmate queen to h8 rook to f8 knight
to d6 bishop takes d6 bishop to g6 every
single piece comes into play with
devastating consequences king to e7
queen takes g7 look to f7 and queen
takes f7 big opportunity for uh jordan
van forst to finish the game at that
point he played the move queen to h5
and yes he did invade on g7 and he's
still completely winning the problem is
he got greedy he took on h7 and allowed
black to gain some counter chances after
queen takes d4 despite the fact that you
are getting the exchange i will have a
lot of control over the dark squares
given by the fact that i have uh the
bishop still remaining on the board but
also the huge majority and very powerful
majority on the queen side these already
uh very advanced pawns b and c pawn so
this gave uh black a lot of counter
chances and unfortunately for jordan was
unable to get a better position out of
this end game in fact he went on to lose
this end game this one was a crucial
game for the standing guys what did you
have your eyes on well
actually we were watching gary caspar
christian uh
very uh nice that queen f3 move i must
say that was like really uh almost
winning for yeah
and it should have been actually a
victory for him
but uh the gct points are being raw
points yeah because
the wild card juan uh magnus carlson is
taking
this who's not on our list because he's
not a full tour participant is walking
away we think with 13 whole points from
the grand chess store standings so it
was very clever of lavonne and bobby to
avoid this woman was such a wild wild
card exactly exactly so
and again those
gct points are up for grabs are on the
right-hand column yes
as we stand it's magnus walks away with
this
those are guns and then wesley and nepo
start sharing eight and seven and mvl
six and these kinds of things happen and
then you say well wait a minute i was
second in the tournament and
uh so it's it's it's a
robbery yeah jordan steals some points
as well and jordan as well yeah he's one
of the wild countries yeah well thank
you yes uh
this big announcement right uh the
magnus is basically not defending the
title right yes it's so important for
him to win this tournament because
imagine you you come up with such a loud
announcement and then you play so-so you
finish in the middle of a pack right so
he wouldn't look that good right no
yeah but now
you know like if he wins in such a
dominant fashion right and then steps
down and yeah it's basically saying that
you guys can play but you know who the
strongest player is right and
doing it in both blitz and rapid as well
um
gary
made a point in the conversation he was
having about the world champions and
things like this and i think he's both
fair and unfair
so he says
uh for him gary kasparov that you know
uh
ding lyrin and
um
nepa play this wonderful match for the
world championship they're the top five
players in the world let's say number
two number three in fact
and well
he he's not satisfied
with
that as a match that could call itself
the world champion because magnus is
still alive and still playing and
winning tournaments as we're witnessing
ourselves
but on the other hand wait a minute they
are playing for the world championship
they deservedly they play by the rules
magnus advocates that's the system
that's the way it works i mean how can
they not be world champions weigh in
christian with your thoughts on gary's
pretty tough line
well i have to agree with gary there's
definitely going to be an asterisk after
this match and i have a feeling we're
going to see magnus back in the
championship cycle in later years but
right now he is taking a break maybe
he's uh going to find his own uh angle
for a championship we're going to have
to wait and see definitely we'll be
having my eyes on that match as well i
mean that's a big match we know that
ding
can uh whenever he's in the best shape
of his life he can be the best chess
player on the planet such as nepo as
well we've seen him play amazing
tournaments and that one is going to be
a match to definitely have my eyes on
but there's an asterisk in that well
wait a minute because you just maybe
contradicted yourself a little bit so
there's an asterisk he steps back yes
but then he steps back into the
candidates let's say
and then he doesn't unless unless
unless the before
unless the fallback changes i don't
think magnus is going to want to play a
candidate to get to the world
championship match okay i think he's
going to try to change the format or at
least uh maybe you know fida is going to
uh change the format by themselves and
then we're going to see a different
magnus come back to the board
yeah yeah so yeah too many and too many
questions yeah it's so interesting that
any other sport there won't be even a
question okay that's a world
championship match though the winner is
the world champion end of story but like
in chess we have such a you know like a
sacred ground this this world
championship match right the system it
goes like in the history a long way and
it was not always kind of established at
some point point it was divided in in
two branches right around when we
finally have it and
magnus is undisputed right so there's
always gonna be this a bit bitter
feeling of winning the world
championship but not having magnus in it
how about we make it like in boxing the
world champion chooses a challenger or a
challenger calls out the world champion
and then the champion decides yes i want
to play against this guy it makes the
most sense from a promoter's point of
view from a fan's point of view it's
just one boxing chess point how about we
have that system well we had that system
right before the fee day after the death
of alexandria alekhine took over the
fide
world championship cycle in fact
alexander alekhine
didn't allow cappa blanca a rematch and
he would play against somebody he felt
like he could win uh
begolia buff for example and so forth
and so on i i actually like a regulatory
body
but what i fear
is that fide itself the whole cycle was
wrong and
whether it's who ye fun in the
women's or it's magnus carlson in the
men's when the two top players in their
field
say i'm not going to play in the world
championship cycle because i don't like
it it means that the regulatory body is
not keeping pace with the players
they're not soliciting the player's
input and that's been the case in magnus
as he said
he felt that way even before dubai yeah
that's and it came to observation it
came to pass that we lost another world
champion whether it be uh bobby fischer
or gary caspar yeah like picking
challenges you might end up like like we
had
in the history 27 years of laska being
the world champion and yeah okay he was
a great player but i mean he has played
like five matches along those 27 years
exactly the least number of any
uh in a 27 year span
the game of chess struggles and yet at
the same time
our sport
is doing fantastically well it's a
golden era and
here in st louis we are having a summer
of chess with a lot more chess to come
we have the saint louis rapids the
sinkfield cups the
uh
bobby fischer we've got the u.s
championship coming up the uh open and
ladies
so
chess never has been brighter and yet at
the same time we're struggling
it's like we we managed to shoot
ourselves in the foot uh at times so how
would you guys change the format
oh for sure this for for me there's no
question
that i would do
in fact what magnus carlsen has done
with the online i love the sets meaning
four
games of 15 minutes
you play a number of sets whether it be
seven or eleven or nine like they do in
snooker you know they have the frames
and you come back uh day after day
but you don't play six months or three
months or one month and you just play a
lot i love that and i think for the
spectators the fans
it's
it's marvelous so a way that i think i'm
not sure if he proposed it but i read it
somewhere was that you play a few
classical games and then let's say you
played three classical games on the
fourth day you play a set of rapid games
and that counts as one point as well how
do you feel about that
i i'd need more information but i'm just
saying that
what i witnessed and i called it was a
uh
it was a magnus carlson finals between
nakamura
and
magnus himself and it was easily one of
the most exciting matches
uh i've witnessed and it featured
everything including armageddon and the
number of viewers just kept escalating
escalating escalating and at the end
peter lako tanya
sachet myself we all just went
what the heck did we just witness that
was the most exciting wonderful chess
matches ever
and it would have been ideal if it was
for the world championship
yeah so that's my story i'll stick with
that uh in the meanwhile we will be
witnessing in time in 2023 the dingler
inn nepo match and maybe they
will also make an initiative
like we should change the format the
format how about this tennis how about
this tennis system that at the end of
the year you have a tournament of best
uh whatever eight players i like that
too i like that you got two groups and
then semi-final final right so that adds
a bit of diversity
but at the end of the day i think the
question is the time control
yeah that's the thing that's going to
determine
uh whether you're going to have a six
hour single game which i think is
is too heavy it's too heavy for the
players it's too heavy for the fans or
you're going to break it up into four
15 minutes slash 25-minute game actually
it also becomes more dynamic right so
you have a chance to come back
absolutely
and once again uh we are about ready to
get
set for round 16
of the final day of blitz absolutely
only three rounds left so mvl will be
facing the ball of nepal against one for
rest
mommy died of carlsen so rich with
ferruja dominguez against wesley saw
we'll keep keeping an eye on shock right
right shaq will be our marquee match up
as magnus carlsen
uh impresses
well the whole world of chess including
one gary kasparov
and once again miro you didn't kind of
weigh in there with what would you do
yeah but that that's for the format yeah
that's what i said i'm looking at you
know
maybe
creating some sort of a match tournament
okay and just call it yeah the winner
with the tournament is the world uh
champion because like
i understand we will have to legitimize
the winner of this tournament so far we
are divided in like those are feed the
world champions those are these world
champions the only world champions who
wins the match right yeah but match is
monstrous really right really gains a
lot of preparation like in half a year
you have to prepare your openings and so
brutal with the teams and everything and
we are off
as a shack opens juan d4 and this is
love yeah so that's a bit of a recent
inclusion for magnus carson he's opening
repetition and definitely is a much more
conservative magnus in the last stretch
of this tournament because he's just
trying to preserve his lead at this
point and e7 e6 uh previous game bishop
g5 had been played and he quickly played
bishop e7 shaq
taking the game into a murano variation
variation yeah and i remember boyd did
the d6 that's sort of uh that the
preparation the [ __ ]
was so deep uh miro i don't know if you
ever got
lost in the labyrinth
of variations that came out of the
miranda remember it was torture yes the
world championship match where online
who is like fantastic ideas fantastic
and yeah he won the match with the black
pieces so fascinating yeah and then
later on in three years and four years
when engines got stronger yeah it turned
out like half of his ideas brilliant
ideas were not working yeah
i'm not even sure how you play the
murano nowadays i mean you probably
don't go for those sharp variations
because everything is kind of solved
yeah worked it worked out uh the move a7
a6 prepping
c6 c5 so shack
was e4 right trying to provoke b494
yeah perhaps but how about capturing on
a4 i know the pawn is going to be a bit
weak yeah but ba4 well
at least i'm achieving c5 into yeah once
you do that i don't think you have
really any problems b3 versus a6 i think
yeah yeah kind of making an argument
that those are two weaknesses of setting
each other exactly a b4 says okay so now
of the knight e4 which is very tempting
what do you even do
now the
idea of knight d2 and
sometimes yes because the whole point is
if you get in c6 c5 like if i just drop
back with my bishop c6 c5 is going to
equalize
so knight d2 i think is
like but then i can go for it after your
pawn oh yes um good sweet show this
right right now
that's once again very typical idea
92 sorry owl after yeah trade only for
bishop h2 check queen h4 check and
sometimes you do have compensation for
that but probably not in this position
this is not my intention
and by the way guys if magnus wins this
one and wesley loses
then we have a champion yeah okay so he
clinches the tournament he can clinch
this round wow there's two rounds to
spam yeah that's impressive
to clinch
a grand chess tour with two rounds to
spare
that might be unprecedented i i'm sure
we
i think wesley was very close to doing
so in paris
um yes was it last year or i think it
was last he had an outstanding
he had a ridiculous score yeah
bishop takes d4 on the board
okay um i must say by the way i'm
warming up
to uh white's position if i can get in
queenie too queen b2 right yeah tie you
down a little bit
and then maybe swing over hang on a
second queen e7 so there is e5 e4
business you have to watch that is
absolutely true
but if i take on f6
you have to which was a good move by the
way
uh
he wesley played another way
to play the modest move bishop to b2 and
then rook f2 d8 and i think for now like
kind of restore that with all the
harmony a little update wesley is
definitely not winning um there's a two
game two result game and dominguez is on
the better side of the equation okay
um
funnily enough i actually
like black's position here this pawn on
b4 rather than being
some incredible weak pawn is actually
covering
a very important square
on a c3
so now it's what's like to move i'd be
looking to play something along the
lines of queen g5 queen h4 because if
you look at it like from d file to the h
file everything is symmetrical right
right and it feels like the moment one
queen arrives to g5 h4 or white queen to
you know the other one cannot yeah and
both boy bishop both sides bishops
pointed at the king right and i would
think that yeah i mean if if it's any
good that has to be done right now
because yeah
knight c6 is actually a
semi threat because that would force you
to part with your light squared bishop
so you move queen h5 dodging five the
image
but maybe just
queen h4 g3 g3
yeah but g3 isn't it i understand it the
weakness
diagonal but at the same time how do you
take advantage of that right yeah some
queen h3 straightforward well welcome e4
to try to drive this knight out of but
there might be that might be tricky not
only that but also maybe i can uh play
the move knight to c6 right yeah make
sure it's nice cut the action like that
[Music]
can't live with that knight on c3 and i
can't live with the pawn on c3 either so
we're eating it yeah if you were
planning bishop e5 then you're running
exactly the same thing bishop h7 queen
h5 check right so how do you deal with
knight c6 right now which he doesn't
play he played that for him i think he
was just saying look i have bishops of
opposite color yeah yeah
c6 i'm happily capturing it right
perhaps knight c6 bishop takes h2 was
also a problem uh could
be
yeah okay so once again knight c6 i
think he's just going to
take it
put the bishop on before
your extra pawn is this pawn on b3 and
i'm not worried
by the way that is really uh but the
thing white incredible and hope for use
queen c2 bishop e4
to try to exchange wow
girls for knight c6 i guess magnus
should have no issues uh making a draw
in this one
no
bishop c4 okay i would definitely put
the rook back on d8 and the bishop on b4
or maybe c5 by the way i mean you can
start by going like bishop c5 in this
position
yeah rook d8 is good v8 is good
you have to push before you
[Music]
queen f3 no
uh no info queen f3 is not a move that
you would say i'm infiltrating
anywhere i mean
the bishop will be so
easily uh
keeping the queen side but simply bishop
and rook down to d2
easy play for
for
uh black
so how do we increase the pressure for
white is there a way to do that which
one yeah well
get f5 somehow yeah all right e4 is on
the board getting ready to play f5
problem is whenever you go f5 i'm
exchanging the queens
not only that but if you go five right
now i think i'm exchanging the rooks as
well
exactly oh so you just capture
everything on a five and give rugby one
chance yes precisely so
okay so magnus is very likely to make
very likely to make a draw in fact i'm
almost tempted to say uh it's time to
turn our attention especially after this
move oh f5 take twice and the thing is i
don't think you can take the second
question queen takes runs into
queensland three exactly not but that
was the show
before take on f5 and take on f7 maybe
that's not that easy
yeah okay so magnus anyway he plays g5
and says i'm perfectly safe
yeah but then
um
i would consider him being perfectly
safe if he would be the bishop on f6
because now you know the queen on f6
it stands there not doing much right at
the moment you move of course uh white
would be very happy to to include five
or six just a quick update it does seem
like wesley might actually be in trouble
in his game against dominions okay
yeah wesley is in a bit of a trouble by
the way guys is bishop takes f7 a move
no it is
wait a minute
blunder alert blinder alert wait a
second how about that queen c3 check in
case a queen takes
how are we doing on time because now
time becomes a big factor 58 seconds for
magnus one minute and 53 seconds why is
he thinking about interesting
yeah
queen h5 is he thinking of queen h5 no i
can't
and then you can take the f5 pawn you're
almost guaranteed to take this but you
don't take the f the bishop
there's a v6 i cannot take the pawn but
i'll take the bishop
if rook takes yeah that's the trick
so rookie five actually wins the pawn
back
wow
magnus captures this one but this is
this is this might be dangerous
to be bad right what about f6
yeah it's already played yeah guys i
think magnus is on the verge he's going
down yeah of losing this one three pawns
for the piece and the bishop is seven at
the very least yeah
pawn
uh
that's a lot of pawns yeah black's
certainly not winning this one can you
fade by the way it's not a bad move
maybe
check and come back come back to the
king side with queen g4 check yes he's
done it yeah
and if shaq wins this one and wesley
manages somehow to survive he's going to
be within striking distance and shock
beats
pete carson in rapid as well right
rook to c8 rook f1 i was surprised by
that one but look at this rook e8 he's
going for me and the g7 check is he
wants to see the queens as well oh my
god
right rook f8 this might be over trading
queen g8 yes and then white goes
something like queen d7 27 followed by
f7 now maybe you don't play f7 maybe you
just put the queen or c7 e7 something
and then you if i
trade
yeah maybe you're winning but but why to
why to trade right i mean three
no then you go queen e it's also the
bishop which was hanging yeah
i would prefer queen c7 to kind of
control
what does he do i mean what was e4
apparently there was some yeah
apparently there was some tactic
i think it was based on f7 perhaps wow
but and now it gets active wait a minute
at least they're gonna be some chat
magnus is back in the game guys
yeah yeah i think so
time effective nine seconds for magnus
okay still a lot of problems c6
not easy five seconds for magnus king to
f7
eight five that's another pawn running
down it's so easy for mommy aro i mean
just push the pawns right push it push
them though
queen c3 without the vol
correct the bishop needs to stay
king
teenage two
big moment right now just to sidestep
these checks on f1
you keep d6 under control
well i mean if he saves this one he's a
magician i have to tell you he truly is
he truly is
queen is going towards c7 it looks it
bishop c5 queen to f5 i have no checks
a beautiful move but he captures
threatening a check on what is a is a
checkmate threat because then it's a
bishop coming to g1 to 150
and you can't really play b7 because
you're still getting checkmated right so
right incredible can we see this by the
world champion but queen a1 is as deadly
as
absolutely
no more problems so it will end up
white protecting against the checkmate
and black capturing the b pawn which
will be a draw
correct
what a remarkable song so he does play
b7 but magnus doesn't even bother to
give a check just just stops it with the
king he sure did yeah yeah and now she's
trying to wait a minute who's playing
for a win who's playing for a wedding he
does play queen lijuana and king v8 what
a great move king v
uh i have to say to c7 wait a second
right bishop d6
yeah
he wants to make a draw now it's a draw
yeah wow
what a save
and shag what's up
and let's jump to that game of wesley so
and what do we have an extra pawn for
lanier
not enough not enough i don't think
that's enough
the problem is i get my king to uh a7
right now still a game though
well you haven't gotten there yet not
yet so the king is now on this race
knight stays connected to the a pawn
yes yeah but that is your and now once
you get your king to a7 then it's going
to be a draw it's going to take you so
long wait a second can you play
something like bishop e2
he's trying to tell by the way that move
bishop c6 was played with one second on
the clock no dominions could also be
losing this one
easily easily easily knight c4 and that
might be a three-time repetition right
okay so king a7 is a dead draw that's
that's a repetition for sure for sure
right
well the players uh
certainly in the case of wesley he's not
yeah so my argument is that maybe you
can give up the g2 pawn if you get king
on b6 pawn on a6
but yeah but
that's apparently there goes the a pawn
oh
king
c7
pc7 yeah
yes
just in time king c5 stay connected to
the bishop well then king e5 king e5 ah
wait a second wait a second well
i have an engine running at the
background and it says that white is
absolutely winning so it's because
did he really find a win
takes yeah a5 was the final mistake such
a natural move right i was a little bit
surprised that wesley didn't claim the
draw just to see if there was a
three-time repetition
i would be surprised if there wasn't
yeah yeah by that point yeah it feels
like they've revealed are those all the
results
yeah
and that means he's clinched magnus has
clinched at least a tie
at least a tie he's two points uh
ahead with two rounds to go uh
magnus is amazing i
he's
he's he's just amazing
he was just sure he is yeah well where
where was the simple win in that uh was
there a simple win was there a simple
win for
er for chakrillar let's take a look
because it sure felt it
yeah like not much was going on until
that moment well i mean when the rook's
right here yes yes rook to c8 was still
good still winning it it felt like
completely wrong can't queen to c3 was
the move c3
and now just get the pawns going
i see b4 so the bishop is not getting to
the face and that's very important
that's the key maybe you can even start
with a5 the idea is that you need to
control the bishop's squares and you can
do that by just placing your uh pawns on
the dark squares a5 and before and then
go on to exchange the queens and the
pawns are going to be unstoppable queen
c3 queen to c3 was a big one but even
after queen to d7 okay b4 was a big
mistake get the other pawn going down
the board but
guys i mean mamedyarov still had a
minute nevertheless it's such a
difficult position to assess right you
know you're better but at the same time
if you allow the queen back into uh play
the king is going to be extremely weak
this is what happened in the game
and at this moment
magnus was down to seconds right
after the move b4 magnus had 10 seconds
on the clock wow
incredible and let's take a look i mean
it did feel yeah b5 was the critical
mistake and this is the moment you guys
pointed out when the queen finally got
activated
b3 it is black who is finally back into
the game not only that but the bishop on
fate is nicely protecting the king side
as well as ready to attack the king
after bishop to c5 or bishop to d6
perfect placement for the bishop on f8
he lost his mojo at this point white
that is
[Laughter]
sometimes you just say how do these guys
do it there's like this one small window
of opportunity and they crawl through it
and here we have it standings after 16
rounds mirror and for the first time in
this tournament mvl is tied for the
third right is it the first time yeah i
think it is because he comes up with 10
and a half
points in the blitz matching nepo but
not
matching magnus magnus is just uh just
amazing too strong uh alireza is having
a much better result in the second day
of blitz the first day of blitz he was
languishing with three out of nine and
he's come back jordan benford is fading
a little
uh but
a sufficient gap for him to
play
outside of top six yeah can't can't do
that
and nepo a little disappointing because
he was making that big run a challenge
for second yeah but it's gone already
it's gone well second maybe there is a
chance yet but no way
that was a huge turnaround in the game
of wesley so christian and it you were
saying that this was the moment where
uh lanier had
played a very nice trick and said
take my pawn yeah well actually just
move the knight there how tricky are
these guys though i know with the idea
once you get your king to a7 and maybe
even the a6 you think then you could
just take on g2 and but this was a a
kind of a tsuji on the night
instantly came bishop d5 and now this
knight well that's so impressive right
there's no way to get a good king and
pawn end game anymore it's gone it's
over
king c7 and once again if you play
knight c6 we'll take it
and we run and capture and win
but let's check in with zagreb alejandro
and anastasia
thank you yasser and it's just crazy in
blitz how one move one decision can just
turn the entire game around we saw it
with vaseline topple off that was a
tough one to watch but guys what
happened to yvonne cyrus is just tragedy
after tragedy anastasia take it away i
cannot believe what happened let me
bring you just right to one of the
critical moments of this game imagine
after 97 um white had an opportunity
just to finish the game just here you
know bishop takes g7 and probably um
ivan was counting only knight five and
then queen h6 probably he saw this
defense queen f6 and that's why he
refused desperation but look at this
what he could do after
king g7 queen h6
and if it takes it's a very nice and
cute checkmate yes after g4 i mean you
basically make every book yes actually
so believe it or not at this moment
after 97 bishop g7 the best move for
black is just to move the night so it
explains a lot right in this situation
so what happened in the game was just
literally crazy i mean of course white
has a better situation here and i will
just go somewhere here at one of the the
second critical moment um
black could just simply white just could
simply defend this pawn on b2 and i
think it would be just much better yes
before this move rook f3 i mean just to
play maybe bishop be one bishop a for
any move basically but after um rook f3
move somehow he gave chances um
ferruccio took on b2 and i mean those
spawns it's still winning but those
pawns i mean you can see that they start
moving at certain points some counter
play for ali reza very unnecessary
quantum play here but still it was still
winning i mean and even if we go to the
final position what a crazy game even at
the very very end you can see that uh he
just simply lost on time with an extra
rock with an extra rook on the board i
mean position was so winning and we
couldn't believe our eyes we ran to the
plane when you to understand what
happened we saw both of them coming out
to players and then i just spoke to the
arbiter because i couldn't ask this
question
ivan purivan really what a tragedy
ah no i was talking to yvonne outside
and
his face was this mixture of pain you
know this pain that you lose a game and
like complete frustration
just the way that this tournament has
gone for him
it's been really tough to watch i was
taking a look at the game of dominguez
and wesley you guys caught the end of
that one where beautiful domination by
dominguez ended up winning uh the game
and remember that these are players that
are going to be playing with each other
instead of against each other in just a
few days as the chennai olympiad starts
on friday yes that's right on friday and
wesley and lanier of course are going to
be participating for the american team
they're the number one seed but in this
one they did not look like teammates
they were going at each other on the
throne and lanier in his usual way very
cagey style these the usual
rookie one berlin not huge wrist but
unpleasant and plus and i'm plus and
unpleasant until wesley really broke and
you guys mentioned some of the key
moments but i wanted to point out the
way that players change their ideas
during the tournament because this is
exactly the position that they had in
the rapid portion of the event with
linear playing with the white pieces and
queen f6 was played in that position uh
we also
saw the move rook d1 and instead of any
ideas with bishop takes f2 we saw this
move rook takes c8 we saw this move
queen e4 bishop c5 rook takes rook d8
and it seems like they were just going
to repeat their entire game but little
but linear understood that this position
was simply unpleasant for the black side
maybe in a classical game you can draw
it but in a blitz it was very hard and
you guys saw that later on in the game
wesley actually made a series of
mistakes and ended up having to defend a
very unpleasant position that he could
not hold at the end actually it shows
that they prepare even for blizz games
i mean yes and remember linear is
actually not alone here he brought one
of his seconds emilio cordova
grandmaster from peru is here he's
hanging around with the playing venue
all the time so you know that they're
talking about openings between rounds
and linear even though he's not having a
great tournament has great preparation
yeah so he managed to beat wesley so and
now it's a tricky situation it's a
tricky situation two points separate him
from carlson and only two games left in
zagreb magnus half a point away from
crowning champion we're gonna take a
small break and we'll be right back with
round eight of the day
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to round
17 as our marquee match up for this
round
we are about to crown a champion we
believe in magnus carlsen as he's
playing alireza farouja the
opponent he's hoped
to meet at the candidate's mural yeah
and what have we got we've got a kind of
a
wow
it's a weird looking
one of those weird-looking queen scam
but declined where you somehow you
traded the e pawn for the
b7b7 yeah remarkable
uh well so that that's one very
important match because if magnus does
not lose i want to say magnus wins but
he doesn't even need to win right i mean
if he makes it raw or better than he is
the winner
in case he loses though
uh wesley saw an mvl who are playing
each other yes then be looking for for
this result so that's another so wesley
so and mvl tied for second
if uh
one of those two players have to win
both their games absolutely magnus
magnificent
they also need a croatian miracle in the
last one because yes magnus in the last
round he'll be against saurage with one
a quick question for yourselves bishop
d6 on the board queen c6 that's that's
no and wesley went for a very well known
draw in uh i guess we have a general
field some magnus magnus regulations
we have a chair tournament yeah yeah
that's it magnus won the tournament he
sure did
and he did not go for that queen c6 yeah
so the question is what was wrong with
queen c6 i'm just kind of curious and
congratulations to our wild card
player magnus carlson first place forty
thousand dollars thirty thousand
thirteen grand prix or grand jury store
points
are gone again he robbed him well
actually i mean can he take
a little bit of this prize fundraiser
because he's 13 points
yeah i mean if he does outstanding in
the sink phil cup
uh that would be 26 points
if he did outstanding and uh
that would be bizarre that a a wild card
yeah well technically he's not a tour
participant so you can just decline him
money and you say yeah okay yeah you
should have played the entire tour right
uh rook c1 on the board christian jump
in what's are we in theory no no
absolutely not that's something called
it's just an easy position it feels like
for white right it's madness is not
risking anything at this point you're
going to pick up c7 probably you're
allowing black to damage the pawn
structure but how bad can this be for a
white i don't see black gaining any sort
of traction with his initiative magnus
got this
okay so something like bishop takes f3 g
takes f3
knight f5
oh we can exchange the queens if we
really want to
take on c7 take take knight takes d4 you
take on d4 and then we try to s
suggest that somehow we can go oh we're
about to start
okay we can take on c7
and
i wonder if perugia did it right queen
c7 queen c7 bishop f3 i have bishop
might allow bishop bf bishop b5
intermediate might be yeah an important
difference between capturing on f3
whether he takes it or bishop to b5
because he should have if he wanted this
uh they they transposed they transposed
uh it should be three so knight e5
knight e5 tricky aren't you 95
f4
drop a knight into f3 and castle and
i'll be i am maybe
castle
where castle work yes well i can't
castle long
yeah
unfortunately the rules of chess being
what they are but then i just go bishop
g how about bishop g2 without f4
right you want to take take i'll trade
on f3 go king e2 and go after your a7
pawn maybe that's the recipe so at least
like i will not end up with my king on
d1 i will be no question about it i will
be seriously worse that's a easy recipe
that is a very easy recipe indeed bishop
maybe just gail bishop g2 i don't know
knight d3 might be well he actually went
with bishop the lazy man's
guide
why not absolutely play clear moves
right right
the rook on c7 being a dominant force
uh in endings where you castle
so we're looking at knight takes f3
we'll trade on f3 you go king e2 and
we'll end up winning this pawn on it
will be four versus four but it will be
two connected past pawns on the queen
side
okay
that doesn't really change
our perspectives does it
yeah castle
castle or castle
maybe change our mind ago if or even
though perhaps what peruser is planning
some sort of like id3 probably that's
what i was my d3 check
of uh but i thought the simple castles
and if you take king h1 yes precisely so
then the knights are tied
down to one another right yeah and a7 is
on tap
that's a a pretty tasty many of choices
for magnus at this point
so and he's playing with house money
right because he already won the event
exactly but also i have to say that
something about magnus's play in this
tournament it's it's just been
that he's gotten nice positions out of
the opening he's never really in it
and
he
he's just at the critical moments
like what he's played with shaq
uh he finds
these moves like it's it's kind of a
black magic
for a second i thought that you're going
to criticize his play no the guy wins
with two games it's just amazing his
play has been nothing short of we have
been criticizing it a little bit at the
beginning because
because at the very beginning he in the
rapid section rook takes a seven
inviting 19 who is the check
wow who is that inviting knight d3
champion
is going oh wait a sec can he go king d2
so that knight b2 king c3 the knight is
threat knight b5 check yeah
yeah but knight b5 checked the rook will
be protected so have a pair of bishops
right exactly
maybe that's enough to maybe that's what
that's what he's going for
takes b2 king c3 black doesn't have
alternatives can you go knight b5 no no
no bishop c6 check right there bishop
but the bishop is lost bishop b6 no no
knight b5 right now knight b a knight e5
no knight knight b5 yeah the bishop
cannot go to c6 there is still this
stupid pawn on f3 that
sacrificed quite a few moves again
wanted to yeah yeah he didn't take it
knight b5 looks like b5
yeah only move knight b2 would lose to k
well knight b5 you go
f4
wait a second what's up what is that
well that makes some sense right because
if you take on f4 you have knight b5 and
the rookies wait a second if i take on
d4 what do you do
uh g2 is hanging yeah but rook d4 king
e3
will be answered e5 e5 first
e5 first okay
by the way the bishop is still hanging
now if you go king to e3 i take on g2
with check that's nasty so that's the
difference
can i go rook d1
bishop f1 was
yeah
playing
rook d1 was an interesting alternative
to be honest because i wanted to play
bishop f1 and not lock my rook on h1
right uh rook takes d4 king c2 on the
board yeah i'm a master castle
maybe bishop to a6 to or rook c7 is what
he has done rook c7 but how about rook
d8 trying to invade
he'll probably not impress right bishop
c4 yeah so that's what he makes possible
so rook c7 to to put the bishop on c4 in
fact good hit
seven yeah the key will be safe on c3
uh
goes 96 to disturb the rook it looks
like a good disturbance
yeah rook c4 perhaps
rook c4 yeah because it's all about it's
these passers right you just you just
want to
and how are we doing on time right now
magnus 28 seconds versus
one minute and 30 seconds for our
libraries like rook c3 so rook d8 is
answer was bishop d3 right so bishop c4
a mate i'm not i'm not
too worried about the the rook dropping
perhaps perhaps but he's done it let's
give it a try
he's done it
and again these past pawns are going to
be faster than anything
on
the king they're great but i do have
some counter chances right knight to d4
followed by rook to b8
soften up your second rank you have to
go b3 maybe actually three and then
something i'll get to the second rank
with both rooks but that's
that would be easier said than done
right that would be black magic right
now a rook rook d3 may be on tap for
for for uh white h3 h3 okay sorry
practical moves yeah like rook d3 maybe
he was a bit
knight takes f3 takes hp yeah like like
now he's done it it forces the train you
cannot go rook to c2 because of which is
the straight knight takes f3 knight d2
is the strat king b2 and let's get ready
to rumble
so four versus two on one side and two
versus none on the other but the problem
is exactly that bishop is really strong
and by the way what is this movie
okay
i've got to say like before with that
uh ali raza has thrown the kitchen sink
in terms of tactics
against uh magnus in this game and he's
done his best to refuse everything
here we go maybe that's the time to
finally start
moving the pawns there no before not yet
a four a five a six nothing so g4 d5 was
really needed to be honest g4 or h4
which one do you start with i start with
h4 right because i mean it might turn
out that rook d5 was like well he wanted
it
h5 rook h5 king g6 that's a problem
with bishop f3 or no i don't never want
to play bishop f3 each three i may have
to end up oh pardon me the bishop
he has knight h2 maybe knight g5 what's
knight g5
ah he's trying to go e3
and then g3 and have the h3 pawn
protected exactly e3 pawn takes
g3 and again uh my admiration for ali
raza and trying to
by the way make the g3 okay you can take
on g5 at the very least uh i would say
he killed that rook d2
rook d2 to stop
taking on g5 and bishop h3 i don't think
he was magnus is not looking very good
right now
uh
so what's the trick g2 he's going to
come give a check for give a check
correct
rook f4 check okay oh
okay
that was a mistake he missed it yeah
that was a huge mistake rook to g4 is
coming and that's going to eliminate the
no knight f2 never mind oof oh
there was a oh night check
that's not gonna be close right oh my
gosh
knight f5 now knight e4
okay
the rest is extremely tricky he has
magnus image to trick magnus is clearly
university six knight d7 d6 finished the
game or knight c5
knight d6 he put the knight on c8 yeah
you've protected with the rook that's
incredible
we're crowning a champion but uh
excuse me uh just a little punch in the
nose before you
let's go to the game of vessel and
topolof versus yan
nepo one of the uh that's the only game
which is in progress right exactly
and yeah we've got you know apart from
magnus's everything else was a dream
john is i think making a claim of a draw
that
there was repetition before and topolov
said
i finished in a draw
i was looking like a minute ago and he
was completely losing
i think he is still lost it's just that
uh it's apparently a three-fold
repetition and apollo is not
accepted
exactly exactly
uh christian uh it was great watching
the magnus game but what happened in the
other uh
four games do you actually think that i
was even looking at any other games i
was having my eyes peeled to that magnus
versus ali russell there's a lot of
drones let's figure it out you're my top
agent uh on such matters we will figure
it out no problem so we have four draws
by the way that's the most ross that
we've seen in a round in a blitz round
up to this point clearly and first are
taking down magnus carlsen let's see
what happens actually in this one the
last one apollo versus nepo nyashi
because i was mentioning uh to you guys
that topalov was just completely winning
now at this point apparently c7 is not
the right move what you have to do is
create an umbrella for your king with
the move queen to c5 do not allow this
uh check queen to f2 because after c7
queen to f2 the problem is whenever you
go here i give you a check and i stay
always connected to the pawn with every
single check i stay connected to the
pawn if you go here i go here if you go
here i go to b7 you cannot pass and try
to go next to the pawn
because you're losing it right that's a
problem c7 was a big big mistake so what
you have to do is get ready to play the
move c7 with the move queen to c5 after
that after the move c7 i'm going to be
able to snake my king all the way to b6
without losing the c uh c pawn and this
would have given white a clear advantage
now that's that let's see what happened
in the van forest versus mamedyarov
well
i thought van forest by the way he was a
little bit better at least uh the last
time i checked this was the position and
let's see they entered this end game
bishop takes uh
e3 no bishop takes c3 never came
king to h2 rook to f5 rook to c8 king to
g7 so now we see the exchange up for
black nevertheless white does have the
two bishops and that gives him a lot of
initiative in the position so let's take
a look king rook to g8 king to h6 the
king is in deep trouble bishop to f8
finally restoring the material balancing
the position rook to c1
this was the position and i was looking
at it and i thought that white will be
able to make something happen given the
fact that the cooperation between the
rook and the bishop with the past f-pawn
should give y the advantage but
unfortunately it seems like van forest
was unable to make something in this
position and uh he accepted this rook
end game with a pawn up but we know that
theoretically this is just a simple draw
after the move rook to a3 the rook has
to stay passive on b2 absolutely no
problems for black holding this one now
what else did we have this game between
wesley so and uh mvl finished in 20
seconds i'm not even sure how they did
that let's see so this one ah okay this
was the groomfeld variation
everybody knows this they've played it
at least 20 times between each other
and uh yes everybody knows this is a
perpetual
known and i think another game that we
haven't looked at was the game between
dominguez
and ivan saric and let's see did
anything happen in this one sarge make a
draw
yes
yes avon saris versus dominguez this one
finished in a draw and i thought that
ivan was putting in the works at some
point definitely not right now because
he's a pawn down in this position i
thought he was better earlier but i
guess he was not yes not that much
happened in this one quite a peaceful
result between these two players how are
we looking in terms of standings because
we know who the champion is right
there's a big fight happening for a
second and third position as well and we
know that some of these players are full
grandchildren participants right so
they're definitely vying for position
and for the grandchester points
absolutely and we think that
the round coming up is actually a pretty
good one as uh i see that we have uh
ali raza farouja versus
jordan jordan van forest
here's the standings uh three-way tie
for a second three-way tie for second
and
nepal
full point behind i don't believe he's
gonna no yeah like he has to win
and he has an alien
and then mvl has to luna it's not
happening nepo is playing against wesley
nepal he's playing against west yep so
he can take one down or at least
equalize wesley alireza is playing
against jordan that's a big one that's a
big one for sure
uh carlson we are not interested
congratulations to the magnus of growers
very impressive uh first place victory
by the world champion forty thousand
dollars richer as well
uh impressive but once again that that
if i could just see those uh pairings
because uh we've got to cut we've got
three players tied for second
now playing wesley that's one of very
important perugia tied for second place
jordan ben forest who is white and and
that was the other
i was wondering where the third one is
kind of slipped under the radar will our
marquee match up you guys like perugia
friend for us yeah i think so young guns
no no guys i think we have to go for
napo versus west nepal versus wesley
that's the one thing that can change the
standards
why can't farouzia because nepo can join
uh the second place yeah well fair
enough yeah it can't be perugia take
clear second
but van forest is out of the equation
right that's that's uh
my logic right here
is the closest in points
is what i'm trying to say good point
good point good point i won't argue
the math
all right we'll uh we'll use the
farrugia game as our a backup game there
by the way
i thought that game that
christian highlighted where topalov is
supposed to play queen c5
in preparation for c6
uh that's so unfair i mean queen and
queen upon end games are absolutely
ridiculous but this was the moment that
he was talking about right here with the
move season i mean c7 how's that obvious
is the move queen c5 no not at all i
mean you know even in a classical game
uh this idea that you need to
umbrella as he explained and bridge your
king so it can you you prepared the move
c7
that's not intuitive you're thinking to
yourself i'm defending this pawn yeah
like everything's protected if i'm going
c7
now right
so i'm sitting there going oh man that's
just that you you brutalized poor vessel
in there
you know yes i'm getting some strange
feeling of deja vu because
i think i've seen
exactly the same man game or a very very
much the same yeah yeah
and once again on the highest scene one
of the tournaments i was doing
commentary one of the worst commentary
gigs i ever did it was a wesley sew
versus a niche gary
where anish was a pawn up in a queen
ending
and i was trying to give some comments
impossible it's impossible and i said i
apologize to my audience i'm just going
to turn on the engine and it was one of
those things where it was like zero zero
zero
a move would be played and it was plus
47.
and then it was zero zero zero basically
that plus four yeah
it's kinda went like this and this and
this
for about oh i would say 90 minutes i
mean the tournament hall was
absolutely empty and they were in their
night hour play
it was pretty brutal
but here's our upcoming schedule
of uh upcoming events
yep so saint louis rapid and blitz part
of gct happens on 24th 31st of august
right so man
is not specific yeah yeah yeah followed
by sink field cup the last event of the
gct the classical tournament yeah and
our
most
iconic event once again absolutely here
in st louis it really is special to be
followed with
champions showdown chess 960 the bobby
fischer random if you will that will be
the 14th through the 16th here in st
louis
and then
the granddaddy of a wild the u.s
uh women's chess championship and the us
open
chess championship
and for those events there will be 28
players 14 in each group
because we're catching up with the
pandemic and people were qualified from
the juniors and the girls yeah and good
one yeah and we wanted to give them an
opportunity to be showcased uh for that
event so that will actually be a very
long
national championships and what a crop
of amazing talent we have in those
events in the u.s
open championship we have fabiano
caruana wesley so
levonoronia
but we also have guys like sam savion
jeffrey shong
sam shankland the newcomer hence neiman
as well who is progressing at incredible
speed right now john burke john burke as
well i'm not sure if he is qualified for
this one because the rating cap is quite
high
um so
it's definitely going to be an explosive
one and then in the women's section you
have the newly minted u.s junior girl
champion jennifer eu who is definitely
going to uh try to repeat her success at
the us women's championship she won that
event in 2019 so she definitely has a
lot of experience a lot of very
intriguing players are going to play in
that one
yes indeed
but before all of that we still have the
gct and we have one more game
to be played
some
patchy parts in this uh
rapid some really upon me blitz some
good blitz games but nothing really
outstanding
uh as far as the blitz is concerned just
some resourceful saves
including the game we just saw perugia
could you uh christian bring that game
between magnus and perugia because
we thought that magnus was winning
and then where did it go wrong for matt
let's see yes
it was definitely
magnus was winning all the way around
here i think so after e5 instead of the
move bishop to f1 it seems like king to
c2 was just winning because if you do
take on d4 i go rook to d1 and this was
the key move i i think he probably
looked at rook to a8 so rook to d8 and
thought that this position is not as
easy but if you do start with rook to d1
okay you cannot take and take because
now you have to contend with rook to a8
and you lose the rook so you have to
lose another tempe the problem is i'm
perfectly set up your pawns are nowhere
close to my pawns right not only that
but it's four versus three compared to
the game situation where it was four
versus two and that's extremely
important and after a bishop to f1 i'm
just simply going to push my pawns this
is pretty much lost a very uh easy
game for white he played the move bishop
to f1 and that gave black some tempes
that's quite important because now i
managed to get to your pawn structure as
well as activate all my pieces and keep
more pieces on the board this is uh the
problem in the position knight to d4
rook to f1 let's see where he lost his
advantage
because even here i thought even here he
he has the advantage yeah it was kind of
cruising yes cruising cruising cruising
and now rook to d1 seems to have been
too slow
the best move was bishop takes f3 okay
guys but these are decisions and very
difficult decisions that you have to
make with a few seconds on the clock
right i cannot blame magnus for keeping
the bishop uh on the board agreed so
rook to d1 even here let's see
and now it seems like the pendulum has
swung all the way
uh to black's favor right now it's black
who is winning
h4 g4
and let's see if firuja did give away
well he did give away the advantage
at some point g3 rook to d4 yes yes oh
this is the moment this was the mistake
we thought rook g4 rg4 was the move yes
rook g4 was the move but it's not easy
right because knight to e4 keeps
preserves uh the two pawns right uh but
after king to b2 unfortunately
exactly uh h2 bishop
you're losing the g3 point and you
actually lose the game right because the
a pawn is uh running as well
big moment bishop takes h3 is easy to to
play right right and then you miss
unfortunately that you're not picking up
the g pawn this is great
and by the way ferrugia played knight f2
seeing that fork on e4
in like a second and a half i mean his
tactical awareness is is definitely off
the charts
and
we're are going to watch the battle for
second place as farouza is taking on uh
jordan ben forrest wesley mvl is taking
on lanier dominguez who by the way has
played very credibly
in this blitz you see that lanier is at
eight out of
17 right yeah
right yeah
and uh
and wesley sorry remind me again nepo
against wesley yeah that's right so
that's it
and guys if the start is not exciting we
can move to that firuja game farouza
versus van forest for the youths
the youth title
title match well remember you had
highlighted those two in one of our
broadcasts that the game started in the
first one 19 years old and 23 years old
that is because both of them were doing
amazing in the rapid actually after the
day one i think it was firuja that was
leading and after day three it was van
forest
that was leading so he won the rapid
portion of this tournament
and really what a sensational event uh
for you
yeah
so it already matched his best result uh
after two rounds
and he's had quite the roller coaster
ride these guys are ready to get it over
with us
true that yeah well and vaseline
obviously for him it wasn't a very good
tournament and he's not fighting for
much he's not a part of uh gct right
overall
tour right but for shock as well he
seems to be kind of lacking energy and
he only is excited when he plays magnus
so he had yes can you remember anything
from shock games apart from his win
against magnus and then did his draw
against magnus perhaps there was
something but it seems that he's only
getting excited when he faces magnets
that's true that is true exactly very
good point
and uh magnus uh still not at the board
it seems yeah well speaking of
highlights yes you were talking about
blitz highlights yes uh i guess
we could
we could kind of find some positions
like for me i'm still
very much impressed with dominguez's
trap against wesley that was brilliant
like yeah take my a5 and also the way he
he was hovering around this a5 pawn and
finally like he almost like okay take it
and we agree a draw
it was a devilish trap we'll ask our
producers if we can go to the nepal
versus wesley so game is you have the
shack versus topolof game here we go
this is the battle
one of the three
key battles for second place
nebo with a win can tie wesley and he's
going to have to hope that
other people uh knock out
mbl
in h4 h4 i like that
yeah we're getting some action okay h5
let's go very promising start here guys
let's go now castle uh is most likely
going to be met with perhaps queen to a4
followed by queen to h4
try to check me
that's a known trick yeah like like
swinging the queen along the fourth rank
yeah
i'm sorry i haven't gotten an update on
my uh transmission unfortunately it's up
to f5h now you have it
now you have it now h5
h6 h6 the way alpha 0 likes to do it
just get the port on h6 and then now
play like play like nothing happens
whoa i mean look at these moves just
like now there is no nothing on the king
side you wanted to say yes yeah no i
would say this i would say the same but
it turns out that this concept is
outdated and
yeah they just keep this h-pawn alive
and then later on in some end game you
know it pays off
wow yeah we should be watching more
engine games exactly if there was
nothing else to do uh knight h2 somebody
explained that one to me just uh just
right here there you go
knight h2 yeah we did he had to go
knight to e4 yeah knight e4 yes and i
guess what he uh was not uh wanting to
see on the board was d3 c4 that sequence
uh he didn't want to see on the board so
that's why he played knight to h2 to get
knight to e4 yeah and not get the knight
to e4 via d3 followed by knight to e4
because of c4
i see okay so we have queen d7
kind of keeping this knight in the bands
here
night on h2 to my eyes makes such a
pathetic
impression i just as
repulsive
i would say rook c8 rook d84
yeah because i thought queen h3 might
have been a bit annoying
okay rook d8 rook c8 knight
d4 and c4 why aren't i just
much much better i think you're just
better right now with the you must
okay
immediately look it's not fischer random
but the knight on h2 and the bishop on
g2
have
almost crossed the third rank
almost i mean this
nepo still sees the defensive and he's
clinging to it and just to give you an
update on the battle of the youth
between furuja and van forest yes
it's an endgame firoja with a slight
edge definitely will be nursing that for
the remainder of the game
okay guess what guys he's brought his
knight back into
play
great stuff huh
well i have to say the history of like
between those two i remember wesley
starting by having like five nail lead
against uh nepo like
now in classical games yeah number one
game from the tata steel the last round
i remember because nepo and the olympiad
had like a 6-0 start
and wesley stopped him cold
exactly there's something about nepo in
this tournament he got a lot of
completely losing positions out of the
opening right i can remember this one i
can remember the one versus van forest
against magnus one of them was also
extremely bad
so he's really suffering in the opening
which is a bit unusual he's really run
hot and cold there's no question about
that in this event it's
strange what he's been doing this
position
okay if he struggles his way to an
equality you know you tip your hat but
why get such a bad position out of the
opening yeah no idea um
here i would
also kind of be thinking about b5 he
played knight beef
all three and wesley went knight a2
wesley i don't even like it so much
wesley thinking of perhaps grabbing the
bishop a move like b3 c3
somehow could play havoc
with the position for white
all right i just picked out the engine
yes white is much better
what yeah by which move
e4 apparently e4 eve don't ask me why
why this e4 e5 and then you kick the
bishop all the way back to hha i think
yes and no
three he was close e3 yeah but i don't
like what wesley did with this knight
before i don't understand i think it's
too slow i was thinking b5 and just
advance
i guess you can play four again e4 again
yeah yeah yeah
again on the second attack right i mean
you know get your pawn to b4 and uh but
when do you agree justin that now
playing e3 for it's much harder oh it's
almost a positive e4 like it's almost
just you just play d3 right but what do
you play next well that's the problem he
may he may be forced to find yeah maybe
maybe he'll be forced to find because
yeah the alternatives all look terrible
i
[Music]
he's probably planning bishop d2 and
then
so i think he's he's going to fall apart
bishop d2 rook c2 right and then by the
way he's hanging and everything's
hanging you're going to be you're going
to be sorry you haven't played e3 e4 e5
what is wesley thinking about this is a
golden
no c3
c3 how wait a second what is going on
but then at the very least i can take by
the way
ah now
by the way finally he plays e4
on the third of the c3 uh okay on the
third of them
whoa
which was by the way the best move in
the position which was finally the best
move in the position
because that some people prefer to play
for a move
oh
wow e
four
and okay
by the way i mean uh
you know
we're kind of uh
trashing the players a little bit here
we've got to understand they they've
played hard for five days then this is
the last of the ninth game and but that
move c3 by wesley is really a head
scratcher pawn takes ambassador opening
up the rook
on c8 is the second best movie in the
position
c3 c3 and by not a big margin
wow actually after d4 it was white who
is already better
so d4 was a cool movie it's it's a good
move
so now how does bishop actually on h8
is going to make a woeful impression
but is he sacrificing an exchange yes he
does he does take it
knight on a2 is also a strange
looking animal
absolutely
so now the knight wait a minute he took
on f6 yeah which is which is very
surprising should have taken the knight
right so that the bishop has to bishop
his death after that right yeah the
bishop had to drop to h8 where it would
be doing absolutely nothing so now
you're just now changed but wait a sec
how do you yeah do you keep the seven
pawn it doesn't look like you do you
don't
you don't because you have knights
rookie one there will be rook c7 right
or 95 or even knight d5 is there yeah
knight
a4 right and bishop a1 rook to c1
that's a very nice way of rescuing the
how about pushing the pawns d5 yeah he's
going yeah go here yeah knight b2 d6
who's winning right that's a crazy
position knight b2 d6 knight d3 yeah you
probably have to take it followed by
knight c5 now i have no choice i have to
take the bishop yeah i have to go
through
i should probably attack the a2 knight
right well d6
d7 you mean e77 no he attacks one of the
knights but that's a wrong knight to
attack no
shouldn't he shouldn't have
just
okay whatever
it's it's a crazy position nevertheless
rook down uh bishop d5 is a threat
among other things is it true
you sure don't play f6 yeah
bishop d5 check will hurt
um also knight g4 potential yeah knight
g4 is yeah that's why you have this h6
pawn yeah i'm saying yeah
by the way uh
chakri
guys how do you get out of this this is
like a crate i'm a rook ahead how do you
get it but i may have to play a move
like rook d8
and just yeah just say
take my rope but i don't take it yeah
well
white might just don't worry
right if you play with that rook then i
just go knight g4 and then if you take
on d6 e8 and that's a mate
i see
so you have to go with the other rook to
d8 other rook to d8 but then even even
then like bishop d5 is a very serious
alternative to capturing this absolutely
absolutely it's crazy uh
it just
why just winning yeah yeah that's that's
the question i'm asking myself
you're the one with the engine there
christian
for what i can see all right yes white
is completely windy that's so
interesting because it seems that ali
reza was losing at some point perhaps
not anymore but there was this
theoretical chance for
for nepal not only to stop and catch up
with wesley but be to get second title
fight for the second place yeah oh my
goodness play b5 and knight to c1
in answer to the knight c1 is not doing
anything you you can just collect
material right i mean take on e8 go d7
yeah go d7 take on d7
6 next move this is just over
that's absolutely over wow
what a g7 ah
crazy beautiful shake their hands
absolutely beautiful
and even
that was a crazy game i have to say
let's jump to the yeah you're in one
forest right still playing this end game
yeah so who's better in this end game
i believe the evaluation has changed a
couple of times already perhaps just an
equal position
it looks like a crazy position because
bishop
f5 check and by the way one minute for
jordan only 14 seconds for ali i'm
afraid
he's pawn down now right if you take on
check on g7 then it's gonna take on g4
he must have something prepared no he's
not wide doesn't he
i'm quite okay takes our bishop f4 is
that's the four is the move he wants why
is that such a big move i i don't
understand
no no can i just take that bishop
we should shop d3 okay bishop d3 it's a
very surprising decision to go for the
opposition scholars you know
extraordinary
to b4 that's a nice move just that's a
good move stop uh b4 and king b3 uh
oh but
he did a lot of c5 no no but wait a
second but
i mean he should be able i would bet he
still should be seven followers
and then bishop f6 yeah but you're in
why c5 yeah that was just vicious
a5 is also moving a5 a5 is also five
okay can we arrange
no c6 what's that but now i can go king
c7 and put everything on dark squares
yes
take some over here
you just go bishop b4 and bishop e1 wait
a second can you go bishop b4
by the way breaking news our champion
our newly crowned champion lost two
games in a row
wow
magnus lost to evan sarrich
so wesley should have played that game
against mvl after all he should have
definitely have he certainly should have
but nvl was in the same position so by
the way
he touched he touched the bishop yes did
jordan yes and jordan is cursing himself
i don't know why yeah you should be
three
bishop e3 yes there should be three b4
and you do get those two connected
passports and that's winning because you
are unable to set up the proper defense
right oh my goodness there's no bishop
basically that's incredible i mean how
lucky can one man be
[Laughter]
or unlucky wait but does this mean that
ali farousha yeah that's completely
winning i mean there's nothing nothing
to to say yeah
just simply king c6 and b
b4 b5 incredible
whoa yeah why did he
wait a minute so you put the pawn i get
it you put the pawn on b5 but then i put
the
is even doing here he's getting the king
there but how do you continue i'm not
convinced
well you put your own your bishop on a5
oh god
yeah okay this this is certainly b6
check would be well or this one is or
this one is yeah just get to c6 go b6 i
mean there's
nothing to discuss here
right b6 king
bag
go c6 i mean i don't know the waiting
move is the bishop is especially
brilliant it's you know this online 15
seconds blitz right yeah but why what
what are you trying to achieve like
we're waiting with this bishop
yeah and then just just pause
exactly then c7 and that's it yeah it
would be nine rows on the board right
seven bishop takes nah
doesn't that was it
i like that this uh camera is a bit
delayed so i was about two resignations
we get two handshakes
uh let me tell you what happened in the
last round please in one sentence all
the results in one sentence white won
all games white why not it was a
whitewash yeah
one word whitewash
impressive uh
who was second who's second alireza
right well i don't wait to say no what
was our prediction is nepo
is mvl mvl and well and ali reza and we
albe dominguez
he got second but was ali reza tied also
i thought yeah
with wesley and with mvl then it's mvl
and ali reza yep so the two friends for
the second right so and then nepo and
wesley tied for third and third through
fifth i guess perhaps and then jordan in
sixth position so i think it would be
fair to say that i won the prediction
contest not really and magnus won the
exhibition excuse me no no no
that's not how it works that's not
allowed
it works not how it works no no no
let's jump to the zagreb and the closing
ceremony and the crowning of a champion
welcome everyone to zagreb it's time to
crown our winner magnus carlson won the
tournament commanding lead throughout
the event but to say a few words first
we have the executive director of the
grand chess tour michael horkowski
thank you alejandra we just concluded
another exciting tournament third lag of
the grand chess tour it was one of the
most exciting tournaments of this year
and first of all i would like to thank
our sponsors super united and certainly
great performance by the world champion
magnus carlson
and now i pass
a microphone to president of the
executive committee of the super united
our sponsors marion varusic
thank you
first of all welcome to zagreb uh
congratulations mr magnus i'm happy to
have you here as a host hope to have you
next year again again congratulations
and enjoying croatia
magnus a blistering performance
yesterday you just went seven out of
nine and after that you seem completely
uncatchable few words about the event
yeah
i mean it started a bit
i mean the second day was a bit tough
for me
and the rapid in general was not so was
not so good but i think i was
lucky that nobody really had
like um a superb performance uh
for instance like maxim and already had
great performances today but they
didn't do so well on the on the other
days
um
so um overall yeah the two last games
it's a it's a bit
um it's a pity to
to bow out in such a way but to be
honest i was
really tired throughout the day today so
i was just trying to get through it and
yeah once the
you know the tournament victory was
there
you can't
care so much but um
overall um
great experience to be here i really
really like
the city
it's just a very good atmosphere here
and at the tournament as well
and hope to hope to be back
absolutely not a stranger to be holding
the trophy world champion magnus carlson
the winner here in the zagreb grand
chess tour guys let's go back to the
studio to close out our show this is all
we have from zagreb thank you very much
alejandro as once again we
congratulate
magnus carlson on his first place and
we're going to go
from
all the players uh what they earned in
terms of
reward money as well as grand chester
points and as we get set up for that i'd
like to say once again a great thanks to
the st louis chess club and scholastic
center for hosting us in this marvelous
facility here in st louis if you ever
get to st louis you're going to want to
visit the world chess hall of fame as
well as the club the club undergoing
some really beautiful
renovations and uh let's see our final
standings for the grand chess turns out
grabs you here we are surprised but
magnus carlsen wild carter
in fact he's not
getting any points he's not it's just
that 13 points that he won a gun are
gone yeah okay so 40k in price money
then ali reza and mvl as we agreed are
tied for the second both getting nine
gct points and
five
27
dollars apiece not bad yeah young nepal
born against wesley saw and tied with
him for the fourth position costing
wesley a lot of money at 17 500 each
yeah well
not as
successful as in rapid but still a very
very repeatable performance you're in
one forest clear six
eleven thousand eleven thousand bucks
yeah and chakriar there was a tie
actually shakarian for seven all right
so well
ninety five hundred each vessel and
double off with eight thousand even
seven thousand remember his last game
now yeah and the win against the world
champion yeah the crashing win against
the world champion worthy of 7 000 and
some final thoughts if you will uh
christian
well guys first of all i just want to
say that i had a lot of fun uh casting
the games with the youtube so thanks a
lot for helping me along the way it was
a lot of fun what an exciting tournament
and i have to say magnus starting off
slow but after that picking up the pace
showing the field who the boss is who
the world champion is that was just uh
incredible to watch but again ali reza
really did well in this tournament i did
not expect it coming from such a poor
candice to be showing such great and
innovative chess and we've seen that
especially even towards the end in this
competition he won his last two games so
definitely ali reza is a surging uh in
our eyes in our hearts as well so a lot
of fun guys a lot of fun cast games with
you and i'm looking forward to the next
one the saint louis rapid them blitz
that one is going to be a lot of fun as
well absolutely christian and first of
all also miro for you thank you for
stepping in
thank you for having me on the show i
felt a bit of a killjoy with you being
guys being excited and me being oh yeah
i've seen that i've seen this movie yeah
i'm really getting over excited about
chess nowadays yeah so for whatever
reason yeah well anyway that was that
was great fun and i just wanted to say
you got a promise to come back uh well i
surely do okay i'll hold you to it yeah
i'll fight you for it too
and let's just do an updated
standings yes please and since emil and
wesley oh well
fabi was not playing level he was not
playing so we have a new leader on gct
standings after croatia it's wesley saw
right
22 and a half two of gcd points nineteen
for maxime so he's tied for the second
with aronian but in
the you know in the other columbia money
is reflected yeah maxime for the time
being is the the top yeah the top earner
that's right the gct
and uh again when they come to
saint louis uh another 175 000 will be
up for grabs and 300 000
in
[Music]
what's happened uh he's
it's kind of drifted i want to say
absolutely
by the way
he's not going as that early anymore
right
we stand and
exactly
and also
as we close out our broadcast of this
really very nice tour i just want to
give again a big shout out to anastasia
and alejandro for all of their good work
that they managed to perform at zagrav
and uh uh
let's take this pics i'm telling you i i
really i the carlson was uh
but so uh
who's buying
dinner whenever you're trying to be
creative
yes i mean we all should have went with
carlson the number one ranked player in
the world that wouldn't have been a bad
bet nappa was a good choice i mean he
had mopens
and i mean look me and vard the chess
experts yeah they're the only chess
experts on the show well guys you're
saying nipple wasn't a bad choice but in
fact i i bet i finished the last one
well always on the spot
welcome to st louis also i want to give
a big shout out to our production team
really thanks for watching uh behind the
scenes we have a lot of very very good
people who make us look good on screen
on audio a big thanks shout out to tyler
and finn here in studio
hurting us
to our places when we need to
and boys i also want to say a big shout
out and thanks to rex and genie as well
rex and jeannie singfield for all they
do to make uh
the
well the sinfield effect here in st
louis it's just absolutely far
marvelous
and to yourselves thank you so much for
joining us throughout and one last look
at what is coming down the pike uh yeah
what's coming up here it is san luis
rabbit and blitz to be followed with
sinful cop those are two events you
can't witness them yeah
finalize the gct gct standings we will
know the walls of the tournament and the
whole tour
then to follow it up it will be champion
showdown chess 960.
at random right starting right after the
sink field cup right and then in october
us championship woman and open
championship united states championship
with a lot a lot of players yes 14
yeah it's a challenge to the players and
and uh just
once again uh
magnus is just
fantastic and let's go down our list of
players uh starting with our tenth
please miro
um yeah so even
sarah yvonne
and
really he had a
i want to say a difficult tournament but
he
there were there were bright moments too
there were bright moments i mean he won
this last game against carson he won a
very nice sicilian against nepal exactly
rabbit if you remember yeah beating uh
the champion as well the challenger
challenger not bad
and in ninth place we have a former
world champion yeah wrestling topolov
for whom i believe the rapid was a
disaster totally yeah he started with
three losses and he
he improved a little bit but never got
his form yeah that's it
in the eighth place the eighth place
shocked
and yeah the always creative azerbaijani
uh player again just he he had some
moments where he
for 9 500 and three and a half
grand chess tour points
america's own
uh lenier dominguez
with a tie for seventh place ninety five
four sevenths place three and a point he
will be unhappy he didn't all he again
some moments but he didn't get his mojo
going yeah
the man who is happy very very very
happy indeed is you're in one for rest
right i mean
you sh you shared the first place it was
in the first place even like it's not
reflecting the sixth place is just one
place
above mahmoud yarov and and the dominion
but he was fighting for the first like
half of the tournament it was a really
impressive play by young
surreal as he said worth eleven thousand
dollars uh wesley
ends it tied for force and it's mixed
feelings right i mean losing this last
game and what a game uh by the way but
yeah the 17 and a half
thousand
will
be okay but the grand chester six and a
half points he needs more than that to
really make sure he's in the podium
yeah so for nepal after once again after
not so flashy rapid and especially like
bare really bad start yes i believe
overall he should be satisfied with this
fourth i think so forth i think so too
and this last round victory over
wesley will bring a smile to anybody's
face that was a crazy game
uh mbl
died for the second
and would you agree or not but everyone
came out of nowhere totally i didn't
really check the school for the last day
but i believe mvl should have won uh the
last days blitz
because he had seen he was somewhere in
the middle of a pack and right and he
was he was winning some games and he
finished his tied for the second just
half a point behind magnus carson
remarkable remarkable
and while
well everybody was watching magnus
alireza farouja algierson also tagged
for a second for the second he had three
points in out of nine in this one the
first day the very successful blitz
today and i had expected that
in the first day of blitz he he
performed uh today
and our champion yes would you care to
guess who is it
i think it's magnus carlsen right first
place 40 000
and a very very deserving like he said
maybe a little disappointed about the
last two games but he had won
the tournament at that point and i think
he just shut down yeah i think that's
what happened
and once again i just want to say thank
you so much for joining us and sharing
your weekend with us we've enjoyed it
and uh tune in for the rapid and blitz
st louis coming up very very shortly
thanks very much for watching and see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
any reproduction or distribution of this
content without the express written
consent of the st louis chess club is
prohibited